[Music]
[Applause]
welcome the fat man I'm oh so close oh I
get I'm so wired man welcome for the
very first time ladies and gentlemen -
fat man beyond I'm Kevin Smith
I am mark Renard oh holy [ __ ] man
we were just informed as by Nate before
we walked out here as well as JC who
owns this place first off welcome to the
scum and villainy Cantina here on
Hollywood Boulevard in Hollywood
[ __ ] California put your hands
together so the folks at all familiar I
didn't know this and I don't think you
knew this we were just informed that
yesterday yes you sound like the
president yesterday was one year ago
that we did the very first fat man on
Batman here at the scum and villainy
canteen it's an anniversary every year
we're going to change the name of the
show right
what is it every year we're gonna change
the name of the show yes once a year man
next year fat man forever
no yeah man it's kind of [ __ ] crazy
so we wound up having an anniversary
show without knowing it but today of
course we gather for that most religious
of holidays the highest of holidays here
particularly on a show called fat man
beyond it is Batman day happy Batman day
everybody such a such a oxymoronic term
happy Batman like if he's happy the show
is over right like is this when when
when Thomas and Martha were killed 15 is
the day that marks the death of his
parents unhappy Batman day fantastic
that this thing is catching on and
trending man it's like almost like a
Hallmark holiday like a greeting card
holiday so we're the like you will [ __ ]
and celebrate Valentine's Day
[ __ ] or like national
cheeseburger day all right it's a day
for a thing I already love I'll have a
cheeseburger but those oddly enough
those days feel like disposable like
every day is like national donut day
overload this Batman day man it's
[ __ ] seems to be like taking a whole
this is the second year they did it yeah
or something I don't know I still don't
know why there was news stories about I
saw a news story like it's Batman day on
the news I was like oh my god call your
parents just in case amazing man we
should turn Batman day into like like a
secondary Father's Day and Mother's Day
like because Batman day what do you do
you call your parents and tell them you
love them and [ __ ] or you save them from
a muggers bullet either or take them to
the Opera just don't take them to see
Zorro whatever you do in honor of Batman
day the good folks at DC has given us
some stuff to give out as prizes that
we'll be bringing to the Q&A session and
whatnot so thanks to the folks at DC
that's going to be nice speaking of DC
national or national Batman day was the
official launch of the DC Universe app
so if you bought the app or whatever
today was the day everything went live
so this morning when I woke up it was
like Christmas I was like I got a look
at the old [ __ ] that I've already seen
and I went down the library man like in
terms of they got the animated series
like first two seasons of n'stuff
Justice League Unlimited they got a ton
of [ __ ] content including legends of
the superheroes the roasts with Adam
West
and the old leg Legion of Doom and stuff
like that a lot of old programming a lot
of Lois and Clark is on there instead
there was they dropped the first episode
of DC daily so I got to see my my kid is
one of the 400 cast members of that show
so she was on the show I got to see that
but I dig it it's really cool and I love
the idea the idea that you could watch
movie at the end of it they're like hey
if you liked that movie read this comic
if you click on it and [ __ ] read the
comic on your television really really
sweet there's a community aspect which I
imagine I'd be way into if I wasn't the
guy that gets a lot of [ __ ] online
already like sometimes they just pop
into a forum be like hi and they're like
[ __ ] off
tusk so you know I am NOT gonna I'm
gonna burden that community but they
also have a store so you could buy [ __ ]
it's kind of like like it's almost like
it was designed by me at age 11 like
what do you want and I'm like all the
good things in life all the DC TV shows
and [ __ ] I want to buy [ __ ] on a meet
friends and they've kind of put it all
under one cap have you seen it are you
diving in I haven't I haven't got it I'm
waiting for Titans drops I believe next
month yeah so I'll buy in when I can
watch Titans they [ __ ] Batman show happy
Batman day [ __ ] it's pretty sweet though
it's pretty it's cool I dug it I've been
digging it I went looking for my
favorite episodes of shows like that I
loved and I've already got him on
[ __ ] DVD blu-ray and I also I'm
streaming other places I think I bought
a lot of Mon I tunes but I went looking
for the end of the Batman Brave and Bold
back cartoon which is really kind of
unsung man Menino the one loves Batman
the Animated Series and rightfully so
but brave and bold was just full of
[ __ ] Wonder and it was a take on
Batman as the relentless very much
comic-book character take relentless
pursuit of justice like to the point
where he rarely ever [ __ ] took off his
mask there was very few Bruce Wayne it
was mostly Batman the great diedrich
bader did his voice and stuff and in the
last episode of the series that they did
they did three seasons in the final
episode was called might fall and
was about how bat-mite hated how light
intone the show was it he echoed like
the audience out there was like this
ain't the animated series man bring it
dark again and [ __ ] like that
so they're kind of making fun of those
people and so bat-mite was like I'm
gonna try to get the show cancelled so
it gets replaced by a better show that's
darker or something like that
and so it's a great episode but at the
end like they wind up canceling the show
and so they have this big party at the
Batcave every hero they've ever had and
they used the euros well like they would
open that episode with like a cold
opening they would have some heroes in
it that wouldn't even be in the main
episode and [ __ ] like that they all the
DC characters were [ __ ] represented
so they were all in the Batcave and
there's some like sad kind of mellow
piano music playing an ambush bug is
talking to Batman and you know he's
Batman is realizing that it's done and
they're pulling down like they pick up
the Batmobile and turn around it's a two
dimensional flat and stuff and they're
deflating like you know the atomic
battery and stuff and so Batman goes
like I guess that's it so I guess this
is really it an ambush bug goes yeah but
still you had a good run and then I'm
gonna makes me [ __ ] cry just thinking
about it and then Batman goes a great
run and then he turns to [ __ ] camera
I can't get through it it turns to
camera and it's my it's perhaps my
favorite Batman moment in anything he
turns a camera and he dresses kids like
you know he really I was watching but he
was still working under the pretense
that kids like this stuff and so he was
I can't do it justice but I'll [ __ ]
I've tweeted it today cuz it's like my
favorite [ __ ] Batman anything I just
want to make sure I get that dialogue
right because it was so so perfect hold
on one sec got demon vamp while I'm
doing this
well done I'm back I killed it now you
can trust me man I got you you got me so
he looks at the camera and he says and
until we meet again boys and girls know
that wherever evil lurks in all its
myriad forms I'll be there with the
Hammers of justice to fight for decency
and defend the innocent and then he says
good night it is [ __ ] heartbreaking
and it ends the show the end and then
they go to the credits and they're
[ __ ] done
but that [ __ ] one moment man where he
says like I watch it I swear to you it's
if you wanna if I was an actor who had
to like do an emotional scene if I was
in a scene with Meryl Streep I'd be like
hold on one sec and then I'd go watch
this clip like you know like this and
she'd figured out you'd be like that's
your secret you know I'd be like yeah
man I ain't as good as you I need this
so it is [ __ ] beautiful man but at
one point in the middle of that little
like goodbye send-off he references the
Hammers of justice and those [ __ ]
fists so even in the midst of this
really like melancholy nostalgic little
like send-off bittersweet little
send-off they [ __ ] stuck in their
version of Batman they were so true to
the character that they presented for
three years that he's good with kids but
he'll [ __ ] beat you up if you're bad
oh I [ __ ] love it and the way
Diedrich delivers it was just like
because he's so soft and he's like until
we meet again boys and girls which is
also heartbreaking but also like hopeful
because you know it's Batman they're
never letting this [ __ ] go to
sleep so he'll be back in another
incarnation and then he was like a
couple months later and stuff but in the
middle of this really bittersweet
send-off for him to throw up and he does
he brings up his fists he's like I'll be
there with the Hammers of justice and
then he goes right back into being
[ __ ] seen it's a good thing you
brought the fists up no kidding man
like your Thomas and Martha [ __ ]
you know but oh my god it's such a
beautiful so I went looking for that on
the app and it wasn't it was reversed
like the last episode of might fall
episode was put second-to-last and under
the wrong heading so I was able to talk
to folks who work at the app to be like
hey man the last two episodes of Batman
Brave and Bold need to be flipped and
they're like are you a beta tester and
but I was like I'm just a big [ __ ]
fan so I spent all morning getting
emotional going through like my
highlights of my and it honestly is so
[ __ ] weird to say like it made me
fall in love with the character like
again a little bit more I think like
during the day and I'm not laying this
on his shoulders but the the you know
batfleck version of Batman I was kind of
detached from especially after I saw
Batman Superman I was like oh that's an
interesting take but it's not what I
really think of as Batman and there are
all these other Marvel movies happen so
we shifted attention like to other
places but after this morning man I like
kind of re fell in love with the
character and you know falling when you
go to your favorite [ __ ] moments that
feature the character and it led me to
pick up Dark Knight Returns I started
reading that again and stuff so I have a
feeling we'll probably be getting into
lots more Batman on this show for sure
yeah I didn't watch any Batman today I
heard just being a contrarian for Batman
today like I watch Superman fuck'em no I
was watching an iron fist today oh
that's kind of like Batman
the goofiest version of it yeah how is
it going well season - you guys remember
how I felt about season 1
yeah it's great you guys he's got a
glowy fist and everything and I don't
wear sandals a lot season 2 is is far
better than season 1
ok I'm six episodes in and at least [ __ ]
is happening and and the writing is much
better and the supporting cast is pretty
strong but then I plays Davos whose name
I can't remember is phenomenal and he's
doing a lot of heavy lifting in this
Alice Eve is playing typhoid mary and
she's great
what yeah they brought in typhoid mary
it was an iron fist yeah it's a double
character interesting but I have two
problems with the show that better
remained one is Finn Jones just isn't
that good he's not he's not a guy that
plays he plays Danny Iron Fist ER and so
like if he was doing that it'd be so
much more interesting maybe that's why
they hired him the little guys got small
hands let him be the Iron Fist er I gave
up working at the RAND Corporation for
my own proctology practice he just like
there's there's something so mannered
and kind of slight about him and not in
a good way there's a way to make that
fun there's a way to make that
fish-out-of-water back in New York
doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's doing is
you know thrust into the middle of crazy
[ __ ] and has to make his way through
that's kind of what they're doing and so
he's he doesn't Center the show and the
way it needs to be centered yeah we ring
that Bell every time Mar consults Iron
Fist
just get your hand ready they they have
now covered for him in the martial arts
a lot by giving him like a little face
mask thing or sometimes the traditional
Iron Fist mask he's wearing so I saw a
clip where they're like in ceremonial
battle wearing the traditional Iron Fist
mask
does it go beyond that scene yes
so he'll wear it in the street he was he
wears like the big turtle neck in the
street and wears like the the cow so
when he fights his bazooka Joe
pretty much it's basically like hey you
know when it's not fin Jones when he's
wearing the turtleneck over his mouth
right fair enough yeah we're all [ __ ]
TV set which is movie savvy we know my
bigger problem is that one of the
reasons I love the MCU movie wise is
that each movie feels like it's a
different tone you know like the the the
the unifying theory of the Marvel
Universe is kind of fun and they can do
anything and so you get like the then
there's the the dark kind of gritty
paranoid thriller of Captain America you
get the kind of wisecrack the Iron Man
you get the fun in space with a Daffy is
[ __ ] you know go to our galaxy
you get blast Thor yeah the last or you
get the kind of like low stakes low
impact kind of we're doing a heist of
ant-man
there's lots of different flavors and
Spiderman was like a John who's high
school movie and so you can kind of just
bounce it if you get a little too bored
with one there's another one coming in
six months that's a different tone right
all of the Marvel shows are so [ __ ]
grim they're the same flavor of Grimm
they're the same flavor of I'm haunted
by something and look the cities I gotta
save the city where everybody sure slash
arm daredevil slash I'm new cage
somebody's it's themed [ __ ] thing to
[ __ ] Marvel Netflix headquarters
listening to this podcast going like
we're never hiring these two [ __ ]
last week they wanted to know why they
don't get a show not why they never get
my show it's just like very the don't
let's have some fun like you're right
man that's true those four shows well I
would say you know you get a seem to be
lighter moments in Luke Cage and an iron
fist than there were and daredevil and
in Jessica Jones but all four of them
are played very straightforward really
and and some of them should be gritty
for sure like I get Punisher being
gritty as fun and that's why we liked
them when they first started yeah
because they were taking it for real but
your point is it's the same taste over
and over and over again like can't one
of them be this is like this is the
Laverne and Shirley of the bunch
you know like they're having good times
[ __ ] squaky show yes yeah like if one of
them was Spenser for hire you know one
of them was just like we're having a fun
detective procedure with these two guys
or michmash buddies and they gotta fight
crime in hell City Hell's Kitchen which
is what the book that's Heroes for Hire
was yeah but instead it's you know these
kind of dim morose treatises on urban
blight and crime and corruption oh I get
it
but I don't need to get that much of it
it's weird you could probably get away
with the Heroes for Hire that was like
more like the episodic TV we grew up on
where every week they were just getting
some [ __ ] out of a jam and then like
moving on and maybe there's an art
mythology underneath you know like we
gotta get [ __ ] this X Y or Z but the
whole time it's not like right now every
one of those series is one long-ass
story and I guess they're designed that
way because they want to keep you
watching and stuff but it might be nice
to have one show in the mix that's more
what are they what would they what is
they let me know make it the x-files
yeah up the [ __ ] x-files so yeah what
are we punching in the face this week I
don't know let's go see it iron fist BAM
and then kind of a gentleman either kind
of ties or look at the end he's got his
own cigarette smoking man or something
like that that kind of like we got to
get on we got our and fist the [ __ ] out
of that guy
but first you know then they get
preoccupied doing something Horrible's
like ya know that shows never gonna
happen but I think your point is taking
it as much as it might be nice to have
like just to throw a man throw a little
sherbert in there would you just [ __ ]
sprinkle a little sugar on top of this
every now and again yeah sprinkle some
crack on him you like what do you want
sugar or crack make up your [ __ ] mind
I've taken the dive yet it's how deep
did you get I got six episodes in so how
many are there total ten they shortened
this Ronnie oh oh that's a selling point
I so weird that that's the only place in
the world where I'm like less that's
more you know you'd imagine but I give
me as many as possible but having seen
you know 13 every season not be happy to
get ten yeah it's not it's not so bad to
just have tend to go on all right I'll
finish it are you into the actual plot
line this time that wasn't an insult I
am I am although Danny Rand is the least
interesting part of even the story house
does misty have a bionic arm yep really
oh yeah
just flat-out where'd they get it Danny
ran he had it made yeah the way the rand
corporation provided her with a bionic
arm is it made with a looks like plastic
but probably space-age polymers is it
meant to be like this for makanda no no
tie in whatsoever no not even like we
got magic couldn't London technology
nope nothing
no Justin Armel which is he's like look
I'm a billionaire [ __ ] all your magic I
just built a robot arm money is my
superpower did they do like daughters of
the Dragon Desert in the episode I'm
watching like Danny is missing in action
and so Colleen and misty have to find it
and so you just get the two them
together and Misty's like hey you know
you're not bad this detective [ __ ] I'm
the you're right
this is the show this is the show get
that boy out of there this is the show
oh we never found him we just decided to
be detectives now and move on
you know without left Danny in the
middle of its adventure boy I sure hope
my girlfriend comes to get me what do
they still keep the Meacham's the family
yes you don't see the dad but you do see
the sisters Joanne Ward the sister
brother sister brother
sorry ward that was the that was the
part of the last first season that I
found like everyone's saying his name
like they should have called the show
Danny because everyone was just like
what's Danny thinking I don't know
where's Danny you've got to ask Danny
and they like this curity guard who just
met him was just like well Danny was
just here like they just kept hammering
that name over and over again that was
the thing that stuck out with me the
most that and at the end they were like
there's a dragon under New York and I
was like [ __ ] this show so meddle and
they're like it's only bones and I was
like [ __ ] yo ho I gave you my time give
me a real drag add [ __ ] this I'm
watching Game of Thrones
that's yeah yeah yeah like you said
there's a whole there's old stretching
this where you see why Davos and Danny
they're their fundamental split like
there were brothers that were raised and
come along together and we met him in
the last by the first one and but you
never see Danny fight the [ __ ] dragon
it's like it's TV show me him fight the
[ __ ] dragon we can do dragons I've
seen them on the worst shows yeah
even if they did like it's Marvel's so
you could get away with doing like
animated just do it like comic book
style like look we ran out of money so
here's a cartoon stylistically do that
or like pay the [ __ ] money
just don't do another don't do a shitty
show and save all that money so then I
can get one dragon one time or like
instead of 10 episodes do a you save
that money for a dragon yeah I would
happily do with two less episodes to get
one [ __ ] dragon
that's math I could get my eyes it's an
adorable notion Marvel sitting there
listening and going like he's got a
point the two shows is worth one dragon
all right man we got you know let's keep
going in the review vein of things mark
and I just before we got here
had a little movie day we did made a new
movie date movie date mark and Kevin on
a movie David and Mark paid it was very
sweet and you bought the snack I did
have others things we didn't want to
commit to each other yeah you know I'm
saying like handle yours all handle is
but it was great we went to the ArcLight
and saw a movie that I don't know I
definitely was interested in seeing but
I don't know that I would have got I
know for a fact like my wife when I told
my wife I was a girl mark just asked me
to go to this she was like you better
take him up on it cuz I ain't [ __ ]
seeing that you know no it's like I
don't go to the movies with just you and
she's like who else do you go with I was
like all right just you broke the target
so Marg invited me to go see the part of
the predator yeah so we just want to see
the predator man so we can give you a
first-person [ __ ] account and review
of the predator how do you feel about
the predator series in general I think
that's a fair question to put out there
indifferent at best like I'm not like a
wild fan like I saw I paid [ __ ] good
lawn-mowing cash money back in 1987 or
whatever [ __ ] to see predator in a
theater man you know you can do no wrong
until he became governor and then
so I you know ice and I paid to see
twice I paid to see Danny Glover [ __ ]
kick the Predators get too old for this
[ __ ]
yes like where's the other guy and so I
paid to see both of the first two
predators in a movie I think I paid to
see alien vs. predator
I've vague memories of seeing it but I
don't I can't guarantee you I went to a
theater to see that I supported the idea
like how sad this is amazing but then
didn't financially support the idea so
but I'd know I definitely caught up to
it later on
I did not see predators with the mast or
whatever it was the Robert Rodriguez one
I haven't seen that and I don't know if
they've done any since then so this one
if they were just making a predator
movie I don't know that I would have
cared but I do like Shane black a lot
Shane Black directed some of my favorite
flicks I'm from writing some of my
favorite flicks back in the day I loved
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang Iron Man 3
aka Kiss Kiss clang-clang the nice guys
there's something else to write what am
I forgetting
I don't know but I like him as a drow
[ __ ] nice at Iron Men 3 leave Hawaii
he wrote that one but yes last Boy Scout
last Boy Scout does the ones he wrote
but so I you know I've long been a fan
so I was like oh he's doing the predator
and then there was an interesting tie in
in as much as he was in the first
predator yes he was one of the soldiers
who gets killed pretty quickly and [ __ ]
so I was like oh [ __ ] man that'd be you
got to imagine that's gonna be like
weird form and stuff and wonderful words
like I was on set for one of them and
now I'm in charge of the other so I
don't know all of that made me go like
alright I'll take a sip of this and then
you know things got very public last
week or two weeks ago about like the
predator had a predator and I was like
why is that part of the plot like yes
but it's also a part of the non plot of
the movie as well so that kind of
brought it I didn't realize it was
coming out now and then also knows it
must be coming out because I keep
hearing about it [ __ ] so I don't know
that I was gonna rush to see it so I was
glad that you asked because it gave me a
total excuse to go I I enjoyed it I had
a good time like there's enough fun
stuff going on
it was pretty much exactly not exactly
like I imagined it but but pretty much
what I assumed gone in like I bet you
he's not a good guy and she's gonna help
and I didn't know there was a kid they
kept that kind of quiet in the trailers
and [ __ ] I might have changed my mind if
they were like plus there's a kid I was
like [ __ ] this but but I should know
better because Shane black always sticks
like a kid stole in his movies yeah so
and not like as a big part of the plot
but he likes to have a child in jeopardy
or something like that maybe it's for
the idea of like look I know kids
probably watch this [ __ ] too and if it's
a bunch of adults running around they
got nobody to identify with here here's
a [ __ ] kid so uh for for me I found
it like entertaining a lot of [ __ ] blew
up I think it's hysterical because it
also kind of mirrors like when we made
tusks it came off of a podcast and me
and Mosier Scott Mosier we're talking
about this dopey story and we kept
building like this would be story like
Oh magic you did this you did this and
then at one point we were in the third
act and I was like aw [ __ ] man we got to
do it like the third act of iron man
we're like the whole time you saw the
suit but then a [ __ ] bigger suit
comes out and [ __ ] so when you watched
us we literally took the third act from
Iron Man because that's what we talked
about on the podcast but that's what
they did with the predator they look at
the [ __ ] predator a nice carry
they're like [ __ ] off kids there's a
bigger predator like they really just
sized up man that was the whole idea I
thought that was kind of funny a lot of
good like dark laughs a good Gore you
know just the right amount of Gorn [ __ ]
like that the lot of good uses of the
word [ __ ] I don't generally judge a
movie based on that but there were some
in this movie that I was like well done
who's the Sterling Brown Dylan Kate
Berlant Kate brown a dude from this is
us right I thought he was great I mean
he took what was at the end of the day a
pretty you know textbook bad guy not
necessarily textbook as Shane black
usually he's got flair when he writes
and stuff so there was something there
but this it could have been so easily
played by like Anthony Hopkins late in
his career
the nor just pick somebody who's nothing
really making it pop feels like he
didn't alan rickman with it like in die
hard where he had a standard villain
he's like well let me put my spin on it
cuz i remember every scene he was in he
was charming as [ __ ] and like you at
some point I mean I've spoilers I think
he's meant to be the [ __ ] bad guy but
he's so [ __ ] charming you're like
rootin for the [ __ ] bad guy man like
ya ice the kid do it
he was the discovery for me me and I
know he's good actor but like he's so
good that he found a new way to play an
old role I thought that was really cool
the dude who's on was the embroid Boyd
Holbrook yeah he was on the show on
Netflix
narcos yeah he's really [ __ ] good in
that show he was in Wolverine as well
Logan that's right he I thought he was
really good but you pointed out at one
point I guess there were there must have
been big reshoots because the end scene
in the movie he looks completely
different yeah he looked in the rest of
them saying he wasn't working out
anymore it's like we done we're done we
just start eating Dunkin Donuts all the
pasta oh [ __ ] one more scene I'll
squeeze into this sure it was it's it's
for me felt like total like summer movie
and stuff doesn't reinvent the wheel but
I thought it it's mostly satisfied at
the end it seemed like they were setting
up for like there's more coming like
everybody threads the needle now for
sequels nobody makes one movie anymore
now they're just like banking on a
universe and it smells a little bit like
they were doing that at the end I
thought but I you know I look I didn't
pay [ __ ] so it was really worth it
mark paid so as the guy who paid not
just once but twice you've paid twice to
see this I've seen this movie twice yeah
you could be honest what do you think uh
uh well I here's I love the first print
really I love that movie
it is it's the manliest movie I think
that's ever been made pretty Bush diggin
is just like slicing off testosterone
it's throw it against the wall and
shooting it with a camera yeah that's
got flamethrowers underneath it yeah but
it's it's also it's it's a wonderfully
constructed movie because it's it's
super [ __ ] simple it's let me drop
the bad assets of the bad ass guys who
are thoroughly professionals and very
good at their job into the jungle and
something is gonna hunt them and it's
not gonna matter how many guns they have
it's not gonna matter what tactics they
use there are going to be outgun it's
it's Ten Little Indians in the [ __ ]
jungle with Schwarzenegger at his most
Schwarzenegger east where is that in his
career that is post Terminator right is
it post Terminator 2 no no Terminator 2
so it's still y'all know something to
prove it's post commando post commando
it's like we gave him lines we think
maybe he can deliver all of this [ __ ] so
great it's got called weathers and Bill
Duke and and Jesse the body Ventura and
and sunny land him the bad guy from 48
hours and how easy yeah and and it
becomes this this it's man versus animal
movie man versus nature movie and and
the way through is I have to abandon
everything that I know about warfare
abandon all this technology and just
face this thing down face my fears and
and punch it in its [ __ ] face no but
it's super you're ugly [ __ ] yeah
but it's it's it's wonderfully
constructed just narrative Lee
constructed it all builds the right way
the second movie is weird and then it it
almost forgets the audience has seen a
predator movie so it's like it begins
who's killing these [ __ ] Jamaican
Rasta voodoo people who couldn't
possibly be the movies called predator
[ __ ] I know what
I saw the last one that's why me for
this one I don't know 60 minutes it's
got a - yeah but this movie it's it's
kind of all over the place like it
starts pretty well it starts in this
kind of evocative echo of the first one
where we're in the jungle and some ship
crashes in it and a predator just like
rumbles into the scene and something
what's going on it's a [ __ ] alien
it's got some [ __ ] and then it's a guy
sending mementos back to his son who
seems to be autistic and okay sure we're
gonna do that I guess and then he gets
arrested because he knew [ __ ] about
aliens and Benny's in a bus with a bunch
of crazy kind of military ragtag group
of Expendables
yeah like the a-team but not nearly as
interesting and then it becomes like
eight or nine different movies at once
none of which ever actually land and
become something they just kind of
glanced off of what feels like you might
have been interesting and then you also
get this feeling that this movie used to
be three hours long and I just cut vast
swathes out of it does feel like there
was a bunch of cutting being done yeah
like suddenly we're on a bus and then
we're walking and then we're RV and when
do we get an RV and how did everybody
get guns all right sure I guess we're an
act too let's keep going
and then there's a predator who's the
bad guy and then there's a bigger
predator who's a worse guy and then
there's Shana Kate brown who's also the
bad guy so it's four bad guys in this
movie I didn't mention the other bad guy
he's just like the bad guy junior bad
guy and there's a lot of bug a bad guy
there's a lot of bad guys but also like
half the bad guys are the US military
and then there's our guys who just
wanting Li kill members of the US
military even though they're all
soldiers but that's fine yeah we're just
gonna kill other army guys and this
total guys they're part of a black ops
complex yeah so I guess it gives them
license to kill those yeah it's just
it's messy in a way that the first one
was super [ __ ] clean and surgical and
there's there's some decent human it
caused shame black and right a [ __ ]
joke yeah and the actors in it earth I
mean what's-his-face
the trivanti roads from moonlight is
phenomenal he's great yeah yeah he's
great keegan-michael key I will watch
that [ __ ] tell jokes all day
long yeah
Thomas Jane playing somebody with
Tourette's for reasons I guess just
because a pound shoe they tackled that a
character with Tourette's and then a
character with did were they saying it
was Asperger's yeah he's on the spectrum
so I almost backed you clearly shame
black is a sensitive filmmaker okay yeah
like I did not have a bad time watching
it but I was never for a moment excited
by it right it was just alright sure we
blew some [ __ ] up and some of it pretty
good okay the gore is great so the
action is fun let me ask you a question
did they ever do anything with his teeth
in the first two movies the first movie
I think that I can remember that he uses
it like a weapon
yeah like [ __ ] somebody at one point
he got somebody with the [ __ ] he bites
somebody with those ridiculous teeth
they have and I was like oh finally like
you know cuz normally he's all armored
up and he's got guns and whatever [ __ ]
but like it's just nice to see him like
bite somebody like oh [ __ ] you can't
even get near these things yeah I mean
most people when you see that
motherfucker's face
steer clear yeah maybe not go that
closed and it's crazy vagina dentata
face so what if we had to was your
recommendations see it wait wait oh I'm
better wait wait till like USA Anna
Sunday afternoon when you're like it's a
long wait man you're asking them to wait
three years it sounds right listen I got
some of this beer here I was gonna drink
it and hunch for October starts at 6:00
and it's 3:00 so I'll just watch the
through til I get to the one I want to
see I I don't yeah I wouldn't go that
far you wouldn't have seen it at all
it's true here's how you get a friend
you get a friend and have them bring you
then it's great value I think it's
utterly watchable fine summer moving man
felt like a summer movie even though the
summer just kind of ended yeah but there
were reshoots right like I thought was
one of those delayed movies yeah they
realize that we don't really have an
ending or this isn't really sticking
together or guess we got to cut out the
sex offender or yeah way to bring the
room down man you always got to bring it
up all right so there it is man the
predator review okay man we're into that
we're ready to do the real show yeah
that one was close we're ready to do the
real show yeah I mean I have also been
playing spider-man oh you got some more
upfront [ __ ] oh dude Joe how is it I'm
only like 45 minutes an hour in because
I've been watching [ __ ] Iron Fist
question yes when you say you're only 45
minutes to an hour and I'm not familiar
is there a like it will do five hours do
you know how long it'll take I don't
know how long my what I've heard is this
story part of the game is about 15 20
hours deep but you could keep playing
the game
for years if you wanted to because here
is the fun of the game as I discovered
it's just [ __ ] web slinging man it is
just navigating the city it is just like
shooting webs and swinging and like
pivoting and bouncing off of [ __ ] and
then just running up and down walls like
it makes you move the way you feel
spider-man would move in space and it
lets you control that in an incredibly
intuitive way to the point where you
just like I could just [ __ ] swing for
a while man I could just hang out on top
of buildings and skydive just keep doing
that all [ __ ] day and while your kids
are like you're missing the point man I
want a medal today and water polo we did
really well but I'm swinging buddy I
could have come and seen you play but I
got this game here man deal with it
yourself I'm now a little white boy in
Queens
look look the Sun is sitting off the
Baxter building buddy I bet you had a
really great day but I show the Baxter
building in there yeah really so wait
it's not based on a movie it's based on
it's like Marvel right so they have
other characters other landmarks and
[ __ ] I'm assuming I haven't seen them
yet because they have all of [ __ ]
Manhattan wow I haven't made it to 221
Bleecker Street yet but imma go you just
wait do you think there's an address
there there had better be a [ __ ]
sanctum sanctorum or what's the point -
wow man alright well keep us updated how
is this but I hear people like his but
in the game they like his ass is amazing
it's sweet it's very very tight yoga
buns and [ __ ] well I mean if you're
gonna wear a unitard man you better if I
can't have a good ass true I've seen
some of our spider-man down by the
Chinese Theater they do not apply to
that rule at all no those cats are
carrying around some cottage cheese man
get ready to throw at the Green Goblin
[ __ ] I've collected all of the junk to
put in this trunk would you like a
picture nah man so yeah that sounds like
that spoken like a guy who's had the
experience I've never gotten that close
have you ever had a run-in with a toy
with one of those cats on square I have
in Times Square
yeah where it's like hey Poochie I don't
really want to take this picture with
you nah man take a [ __ ] picture
because it's New York and they're
insistent yeah take a picture [ __ ] take
a [ __ ] picture I'm sorry man go to
work now you don't I do though I had a
job really yeah can I have a job no take
my [ __ ] picture then me and Jay
always talk about like if [ __ ] gets real
slow we'll put on the outfits and go
down to Hollywood Boulevard just hang
out from the Chinese and that'll be 10
you know we're gonna undercut everybody
we're gonna go for 10 bucks which is
really only five bucks a piece but
whatever times are tough listen Bob I
get it man but you got to put on some
weight yes like you're the least
convincing Silent Bob like some kind of
[ __ ] crack addict playing sound Bob
you got any other I have no more
adventures I got one up front adventure
I am leaving
Wednesday to fly to Vancouver to fly
with Supergirl I'm making another
episode of Supergirl I get to go and
play with my friends I haven't seen them
since last year around this time I think
I want to do an episode of Supergirl as
well so that'll be good I've taken a
peek at the script it's the mid-season
finale I guess is what they call so it's
or right before the crossover I'm gonna
forget what position it is but it's
pretty cool episode man so I'll be gone
for a little bit but but me and Mark are
gonna do an episode of fat man on Batman
I know we will we will not do an episode
of famine on Batman
[Applause]
it's gonna take a while man me and Mark
will be doing a fat man beyond like
rebranding is always a terrible idea but
but you know I got to remember the name
it's the girlfriend fiancee problem
where you just keep on calling your
fiancee your girlfriend for like a year
and she [ __ ] hates you for it
I've been working for this and you're
not gonna give me my fiancee I also
didn't marry a black girl so I don't
know why we're stereotyping [ __ ]
I went straight to Tisha Campbell yeah
man supergirl be a good time and whatnot
but while we're in Vancouver mark will
join me and at the Rio Theatre there
we're gonna be doing an episode of fat
man Beyond so there'll be something for
people to hear in the podcast feed over
the course of the next few weeks
keep it stoked we'll try to keep the
fires going for you but that's all I
think that's all i got for upfront other
than this I'm doing I did yoga on
Saturday what for the first time
yeah I've been hiking Runyon every day
and [ __ ] and then last Saturday I did
yoga for the first time week ago and I
[ __ ] hated it and it's so weird cuz
it seems like it should be so easy like
lay on the ground I'm like all right
like now do [ __ ] I'm like what so you
know they teaches you and then you're
learning poses at the same time it's
like bless you it's really [ __ ]
complicated complicated for me was the
they keep telling you to breathe and I
don't I'm not used to breathing that
much I guess unless I've got a joint in
my mouth so like they were like you're
not breathing you're not breathing I
think I'm alive I must be [ __ ]
breathing man but like you're not doing
it the way you're supposed to so you
know about 25 minutes into it I was
really resenting it like I'm never doing
this [ __ ] again and then at the end of
it I was like you know what I gotta face
my fears and do it one more time
so I'm gonna do it tomorrow morning but
this is the charming part of the story
you kid Jason Mewes is coming to do it
with me
Jay and Silent Bob do yoga so I'll let
you know we get together next time how
that went man I'm hoping he brings an
orangutan then we can relive the whole
movie adventure together again but the
two of us together man you'll be sitting
there Sal you're taking the Sun and [ __ ]
if you stick with it for like ten years
and suck your own dick I'm on a schedule
of two years mark I ain't waiting ten I
want results did you ever see that SNL
skits with Will Ferrell who he's playing
it's all [ __ ] yoga thing and he's
just a dude sitting on the mat and he's
like alright today we're gonna do
[ __ ] downward dog and he's just
sitting there he's gonna sweat pants and
he just tucks his head under his sweat
pants and goes to [ __ ] town and the
entire class is like sir I'm sorry you
can't [ __ ] do that it's like listen
I've been practicing yoga for 15 years
to get here and I just [ __ ] got here
you're never gonna not be doing this at
Yoga it just goes back on his [ __ ]
I'm gonna hear like what I'm [ __ ]
around my wife tonight is you going I'm
not about it take the bucket Hamburglar
eating [ __ ] rah rah rah
[Applause]
burly birdie the early birds like ah
because I think that's the only girl in
McDonald and isn't it it's like do you
ever think about that Oliver no man it's
like stocked with men and monsters yeah
unless grimace is I think we don't know
grimace is what they got rid of the
women for they were like we will never
need women again we have this a giant
butt plug it's weird though man there's
not a single representation if I'm a
little girl and I'm hungry I'm not gonna
go to [ __ ] McDonald's you don't like
women they didn't even have Burger King
no representation there either what was
it like to be a young girl at a
fast-food restaurant in the 70s we are
going to Wendy's [ __ ] right now that's
right they finally got there maybe
that's where it came from Wendy's is
like I see a hole in the marketplace
girls are being underserved and [ __ ]
like that we can make girls fat too that
means it's time to jump into the first
part of the show the shows that divided
roughly into two parts the first part
requires mark in his free time before he
gets here to go to the internet find the
latest news bring it back alive and he's
done that man give it up for mark he's
brought you the know I have done my best
cut and paste in this week yeah smarter
not harder that's what I say I see a two
silver pins but I don't see a black
sharpie anybody got a black sharpie
yeah meanwhile oh you go I'm sorry I'll
go in converse so hey there was some DC
Universe movie news this past week big
DC Universe movie news for heaven's
sakes
yeah and shocking and confusing as we
still don't know the real story go ahead
Jon Hamm really wants to be Batman oh
that's what you're beginning well as
Batman
then I'm gonna that's true good point
I'm gonna cap this marker and pay close
attention um I'd roll deep on John Hamm
is Batman I think that's a brilliant
idea I've been saying it for [ __ ]
years I've been saying like even when
they cast at Ben I was like look he's
great and yeah he'll do a great job but
[ __ ] John Hamm was right there and stuff
so it looks like he was on a show a
sports show yeah he did an interview
with a guy named Graham Bing juror in
London I think and he says it depends on
the script what the story is I am a huge
comic book fan always have been I've
read comic books since I was a 9 or
younger mm-hmm and I'm pretty
knowledgeable about a lot of them and I
like the genre and I like when they're
done well he's never been offered
anything but I think the internet wants
what it wants
truer words have never been spoken truth
I did I saw I saw the clip and he said
like I've been in the rooms with the
people that give those jobs and make
those decisions and never once have they
been like we want you to be in Batman so
he says but clearly the Internet wants a
totally one and he would be down for it
oh my God he's so Bruce Wayne he's more
Bruce Wayne than Bruce Wayne like and
put that [ __ ] suit on that guy or a
stunt person it'll be [ __ ] fantastic
I mean that's what they do let's be
honest yeah so I think I support that a
hundred percent I hope to god doesn't I
mean well Matt Reeves is that who's
doing the yeah but it sounds like he's
doing a younger or maybe not younger but
like he ain't doing the DC Universe
ended universe he's not doing batfleck
No
so it doesn't sound like Hamm could be
Batman for him but it's it's still
unclear precisely what Matt Reeves is
Batman is and whether that is the Batman
that we would see in maybe his cameo in
the next couple of Wonder Woman movies
given that those are never gonna stop
happening do you think they'll they'll
put other heroes into those Wonder Woman
movies do you think they'll bring in a
Batman or Superman cameo it never
occurred to me I guess they could but it
just would seem pointless because
they're doing well so far
I guess maybe you wait until it sags and
okay look who stopped by it's my buddy
Batman you know I think it's less trying
to prop up the Wonder Woman movies with
other heroes but introduce other heroes
and the Wonder Woman movies I don't know
if they're introduced well I'm a maybe
but they don't seem interested in doing
a universe anymore they just seem
interested in going back to the way they
used to do things which was like we're
just gonna pick movies to make and we're
gonna make those movies it could be they
won't necessarily be connected anymore
they might not be but they still could
be because you you still have a there
was a Justice League movie that had a
Wonder Woman in it yeah so that has that
Wonder Woman no less and that one also
that Aquaman who is also coming very
soon totally so it's Wow what a weird
[ __ ] mess it is at this point cuz you
had a Batman you had a Superman and for
all we know they're both gone as we'll
get to the next story and now the other
members of the Justice League they're
gonna keep going each one getting their
own movies Wonder Woman now getting her
second Aquaman getting his first and the
flash movie apparently with Ezra Miller
is happening next year so you know what
are they gonna do like well I guess they
can never be like hey let's ask Batman
for help they're like you know or they
just recast him and pretend like it
never happened
you know which is just James Bond it
just [ __ ] James Bond it or just
Batman it like oh here's another [ __ ]
guy we're just watching another movie
yeah you know and that happened to be
the guy who changed but that's fine you
know but I think that that using Wonder
Woman as the one that works as the the
beachhead for everything else is smart
kind of makes sense but yes Jon Hamm is
down he I'd have to work out a lot he
says which I don't love why would he
he's already cut from God's own wood
like [ __ ] how much more could how much
more in shape could you get like it just
doesn't make sense to me man yeah but
he's not making a TV show right now
so [ __ ] think he's put on like a bunch
of pounds and Spain if you don't have to
work out which clay he doesn't love
doing I bet you he's not
excellent point counselor I hope to god
that happens I that would excite me no
end I think that would be great marriage
of actor and material probably the best
yeah I mean the the the one thing
arguing against it is he's a little bit
older than I think they'd like their
Batman to be true how old is it this
point he's mid-40s I think is he really
yeah no I'm mid-40s I would imagine he's
younger than me
maybe not he just he would I would hate
to find out we were the same age and
then that I could look like that if I
tried like I am how old we are then like
I'm 48 a little older that's why I look
this way yeah [ __ ] Idris Elba is
46 is he really yeah
that's not fair to anybody though yeah
and he's gonna look like that until the
day dying
Wow there was I once had an opportunity
to interview him for The Hollywood
Reporter they were like hey so cuz I
pitched a big [ __ ] HSL up a story and
they're like do you want to interview
him I said I can't why I can't be in
that room with that dude like my ego
would not survive the hit of knowing
that he and I were born the same [ __ ]
time we have mostly the same [ __ ]
jeans and I ended up like this and he
ended up like that I can't like go back
to my life knowing what I now know yeah
but I bet you you'd leave the meeting
and he'd be depressed cuz he's like I
can't write a comic book
yeah but also I've never had to write a
comic book to get laid because I look
like this wait you write comic books to
get laid
I'll do whatever I can easier ways to
get laid man I've ever had to be funny
or smart or witty or anything because I
look like this
said you yes Oh cause I've had to be all
of those things because I look like this
if you if you were if you called
somebody and told them you were Idris
Elba could you pull it off
I get black Klansmen that [ __ ] as long
as I have to show up let's close our
eyes go ahead you try being yourself Oh
[Applause]
bring us there Luther that's a great
line man they threw you a line do that
one [ __ ] I'm trying to here you want me
to warm you up yeah whoa this is a dress
Elba and Luther Alice there you go
there's your warmup I need the line and
Apocalypse is the end of that I need to
run who's got the exact line they pull
it up it is something I can't to die we
can't so the apocalypse I mean I'm
pretty sure you're a Luthor at this you
find it it's coming it's coming up now
Khan it's my favorite deliverance Star
Trek when he's just like Cory and he's
[ __ ] he's got a glass eye it's coming
up now Khan like in a very like almost
like a secretary kind of way what do you
got all right oh [ __ ] the hole at the
edge of our hope at the end of our time
we have chosen not only to believe in
ourselves but in each other today
there's not a man or woman in here that
shall stand alone not today today we
face the monsters are at our door and
bring the fight to them today we are
canceling the apocalypse
I mean it gets a little wibbly-wobbly
the the take-off was very wobbly but
they you stuck the [ __ ] landing man
that's the important part
that's all anybody remembers what is
happening you this [ __ ] in your
throat that's good good now say Odin
some yeah do you think he gets to come
back like if they all [ __ ] died
Martha but but he didn't he didn't the
ash away yeah he wasn't snapped
so that means Loki ain't coming back I
in my gut I feel like that's the rule
like if you died for real died then you
don't come back if you turn into dust
you say Loki was a mirage who said that
he says he's right-handed hold on this
is [ __ ] important right here
everybody shut the [ __ ] up man you've
got a point cuz I'm sitting there
watching ivory watched an infinity war
again last night I was like I can't
believe they [ __ ] killed Loki go
ahead man you're a thick kiss stand up
son
take this microphone tell us your name
what's your name my name everyone give
it up for Scott where's that my JC's
busy all right take this Mike just tell
us your theory so you can re-watch clips
from infinity war and they show Loki's
hand the whole time and the whole time
his hand is right here by his hip it
looks like
yeah so the whole time you can rewatch
infinity war I've seen this clip where
Loki's left hand is to his side it looks
like he's holding a dagger the entire
time his hand never changes till he goes
and approaches Thanos and you know the
whole line then reaches for him but
everybody thinks that in the theory they
have he's right-handed and every other
clip that he actually stabs people it's
in his right hand he uses his left hand
gets frozen they knew he was joking the
whole time about it I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna forgive the fact you call them
Fey knows and because that [ __ ] that's
a strong theory so it could be that he
who's being a trickster yet again that's
right that's what I [ __ ] that last
night man I rewind so [ __ ] up we gotta
watch it together
look last night when I was watching it
that's the line I hung on which is where
he goes the Sun will shine on us again
brother and then he gets killed and Thor
should have been like I guess you were
wrong [ __ ] but uh but you know he
doesn't and that made me think like
maybe there is a play here instead
dramatic irony oh so so he is dead
you're saying I like his version better
don't kill that guy he was so good and
he was just becoming a good guy too like
loki was super low-key anyway alright so
where were we [ __ ] we really got off
track yeah we derailed a bit just a
touch um Johnny I'm Batman
Jon Hamm Batman all for it man [ __ ] that
that's I'm gonna now I'm gonna go watch
it again just to watch the knife hand
and [ __ ] Oh like you weren't gonna watch
it again anything I know lucky maybe
some fancy-ass news now I'm gonna watch
it again because it's Saturday it's
utterly [ __ ] watchable man it may be
I think of right next right up there
shoulder to shoulder with Iron Man I
think of all the Marvel movies the first
Iron Man is utterly rewatchable like you
can watch it then when it's over he
could start again it's a fantastic like
human adventure and I think this
infinity wars the same thing like it
ends and I'm like I want to [ __ ] I
just want to see Tony Stark in the
sanctum sanctorum as it dawns on him
that his nightmare is coming true I
think that's like I think Robert Downey
jr. is wonderful in all those movies but
if that performance is unsung because if
you watch all those movies tied together
he's been scared about this [ __ ]
since Avengers and it comes to plastic
of my favorite moment in that movie is
when fan oohs were Thanos says
get a little of that phenol his money go
stark and [ __ ] he goes you know me
and he goes I do his delivery is so
[ __ ] dope man and he's like you're
not the only one cursed with knowledge
just the idea that he [ __ ] knew about
this earth man and [ __ ] like that
that performance is [ __ ] magic it's
really really good though won't ever
give that dude an Oscar for that role no
but they should [ __ ] these categories of
like best popular movie they should have
an Oscar category that's like we're
sorry we [ __ ] up we never noticed how
amazing you were and [ __ ] and then they
can give you a retroactive Oscar or
let's say you play a character more than
three times you should win an Oscar like
getting a set of steak knives or
something like that because they would
give one a Robert Downey jr. that
performance is so [ __ ] good that's
why when he got [ __ ] stabbed in that
and infinity war and I saw it in the
theater I was like nah look I lean
forward and [ __ ] screamed and [ __ ]
and every time I watch it at home he
gets stabbed not know what's gonna
happen in [ __ ] and I'm still like oh my
god and then I remember I'm like he'll
be fine he'll be fine calm the dogs down
and [ __ ] like that
I watched again not nearly as many times
as you have but I remain astonished by
how much I'm in love with Chris
Hemsworth or now in ways that I wasn't
before yeah but this weird mixture of
like the the the war-weary
gravity plus kind of just [ __ ] funny
and hilarious right but watching him I
mean Ragnarok was the kickoff but
watching him acknowledge how tragic his
life has been with a smile is amazing as
he goes through his family and
everything for bastards from here to the
other side of the galaxy
it's basically a dress Elvis oh just
roll with me it's my all-purpose [ __ ]
man yes
and it's like you know everybody that
I've ever met like has either died or
that I've killed and the ones that I
didn't haven't killed always want a
piece of me and I'll keep going and
maybe one of them will get me maybe they
won't but I gotta keep trying I gotta
keep moving just that sense that his
life is filled with mortality and he has
no choice but to kind of smile at it
because otherwise he would never get out
of bed you know what it seems like it
seems like over the course of those
Marvel movies they've figured out that
he's got great range they're like oh my
god we can play this guy like a fiddle
like you know we keep trying to cast him
into one mole the block beep [ __ ] Thor
but instead they were like let's use all
this charming [ __ ] he's good at and
craft that onto Thor look at his DNA to
it not vice-versa it's kind of a smart
decision I hope he keeps going I mean
the way you were just talking about it's
true
he's almost that whole movie is almost
like one long I'm ready for death
monologue yeah and I hope they don't
[ __ ] kill him off I was gonna say
that Candy's a god but we watched Loki
get killed but then you said he might
not be killed so he's [ __ ] movies man
they really take up a lot of headspace
in my life and [ __ ] stopped caring about
real people because I give a [ __ ] about
fictional characters alright where to
next
[ __ ] Henry Cavill that's the big news
of the week
more so than bad ham I would imagine as
this henry cavill news which is puzzling
because it's not been confirmed but
meanwhile tell them what's going on so
far well the what apparently has
happened is that Warner Brothers has
decided not to develop any more Superman
movies which sidebar that's a mistake I
think you need to keep your big guy
vital this is the very first superhero
ever created the king of the superheroes
if you will they want to pave the way
for everybody else while we're in this
you know amazing era this Renaissance of
comic-book movies don't leave your best
guy on the bench just [ __ ] hand it to
somebody who's gonna make it what
everybody knows that character to be
character is a symbol of hope man like
go back and watch ten minutes of a
Christopher Reeve Superman and use that
as the DN
they for what they do going forward man
it's not about like some Christ parable
or he's this [ __ ] alien from another
world he's just a good [ __ ] dude it's
that simple you can make a movie about a
good [ __ ] dude I rewatched Superman
of on the app they'd be there playing
Superman the movie so I rewatched him
saving Lois Lane the sequence with the
helicopter and [ __ ] like that and then
his first flight and he goes and you
know stops the bank robbers like his
first night in Metropolis I don't say
this because I was a boy when I saw it
in 1978 reminds me of like being a child
yes of course that's mixed up in it but
I'm a you know purported to be a
storyteller for a living from time to
time and stuff and as that person it's
so insanely wonderful wonderfully
crafted and tells you so much about what
that character is one montage of him
doing [ __ ] like when you think about Man
of Steel and this ain't me bitching and
we're about it or [ __ ] on or trying
to lower it but like you know remember
the scene where Superman fights with the
dudes in the bar like throw a drink in
his face and then he [ __ ] up their
18-wheelers with telephone poles or
whatever [ __ ] it is like that that tells
the story right like yeah hey man he's
strong but it also tells the story of
like it's kind of [ __ ] petty like you
know I know he's not quite Superman yet
he's on the road to being Superman so
you get away with stuff like that but
like the Christopher Reeve the dick
Donner version of Superman is just so
beautiful and so simple and that
character is beautiful and simple but
not simple like he's stupid but simple
that it can appeal to anybody you know
what I'm saying and I like like the the
notion I don't know if it was a rumor or
whatnot but they were saying hey Michael
B Jordan is Superman great get somebody
in the [ __ ] outfit don't put them on
the [ __ ] bench don't be like we're
just now we're doing super girls if they
just discovered they had this other
character and stuff do your Super Girl
movie absolutely but Superman like this
is an icon you know the same way you've
always got a Batman movie in production
should be a Superman movie in production
as well if it's not henry cavill like
there's a lot of other people that can
wear that cape
but they should not be shelving their
biggest character at this point in time
that's what I think but I don't run the
studio yeah
and and they shouldn't be afraid of what
Superman is you know which to me is kind
of what Man of Steel was kind of what
Justice League was but what ironically
Captain America isn't yes is the you can
just tell a straight-up [ __ ] good
person and not have to look askance at
and not have to like temper it with some
semblance of grit and realism just have
him be a [ __ ] dude who flies who
believes in the good thing because he
was raised by good people and I
understand we live in a different world
now a more cynical world and bad shitty
things are happening all the time
but you know you can do they did that
with Captain America yeah like they had
a guy who was [ __ ] true blue and [ __ ]
like that and then slowly realizes the
world around him is not the world he
became Captain America in and stuff so
even he's at odds with his environment
and or government but nobody ever like
says these Marvel movies are you know
[ __ ] anti-government or some but
truly Captain America has a problem the
government the government is run by you
know [ __ ] Hydra so they get away with
it that way but they're telling
compelling story fiction because it's
yes thank God that could never happen
here hella Hydra but like they're
telling this pretty compelling story
about essentially a boy scout a
do-gooder I was never a big Captain
America fan for that reason it's like oh
it's [ __ ] boring man just like this
person but they wound up telling a story
where I'm like wow they made him human
and it's more about him being the man
inside the hero not the super so much as
the hero itself so they could do that
with Superman you're right they
shouldn't be afraid of the character
they shouldn't even be afraid of the
like truth to like everywhere now it's
will do truth and justice but we can't
[ __ ] do the American Way and I'm not
sitting here standing up for like hey
man America and [ __ ] like the people
that got mad at Ryan Gosling because
there's no flag in the moonshot movie
they did and stuff not saying that but
this is a part of this characters DNA
where's the colors of the country and
stuff just lean into that you know it's
real [ __ ] simple and you want to
talking about bridging and divide if you
get a Superman movie right you got
[ __ ] you know conservatives and
liberals at the end of the day here's a
bleeding-heart [ __ ] liberal if ever
there was one this [ __ ] Superman pull
it cats out of trees and [ __ ] like that
but he's like the strongest symbol for
America since like the bald eagle so I
would be working on that that's what I'd
be working on a movie that could bring a
divided country together under the
[ __ ] auspices of a character that has
been proven time and time again for
decades to be enjoyable to multiple
guests and whatever it cost you get Brad
Bird to make that movie [ __ ] yes yes
whatever it's [ __ ] car
god damn it if somebody understands the
superhero psyche very well and has made
very human superhero movies cool stuff
I'll star Superman they could do
absolutely all right so finish the story
about him so yeah so they are not
developing any more superhero movies and
I think you know and with that comes
severe Superman movie Superman and with
that comes the releasing of Henry Cavill
from his contract which he wasn't really
adhering to given they wanted him in for
a cameo in Shazam I'd heard that that
they wanted him to pop up toward the end
of the movie to like give Shazam the boo
Captain Marvel shows am rather the
blessing right but he's not doing it you
know so it seems as if he is a little
bit of a casualty of the fact that DC's
first real push into connected
University didn't work the way they
wanted it to and that he was harshly the
Keystone of the first leg of that
particular run he was to be fair mana
steel begins the Snyder verse totally
but yeah so so I feel bad for him
because I like Henry Cavill quite a bit
like I think he [ __ ] overloaded his
arms in Mission Impossible fall out you
know and Man From UNCLE is super
enjoyable you've said that a few times
you enjoy really [ __ ] charming in
that I think he's a fantastic actor but
I don't think that these were the but
these were the best superhero the
Superman movies for him because they
never required him to be charming
well they gave him one they gave him one
movie and then the next movie was
supposed to be his but then that became
a back door Batman movie
right you know so I think they they said
the last one was Justice League and that
did yeah he's barely entities in the
last like 15 20 minutes or something
yeah so I just so I don't think we've
ever seen
truly what his Superman would be and I
feel I feel like we're being short
rifted a little bit as an audience and I
definitely feel like he was as an actor
because there's there's a world in which
that dude has a ton of range and looks
the part and could be could be the
magnetic Superman you always wanted but
never God now they there have no
intention of doing a Super Man of Steel
to obviously or anything I know that
sound they're they're deep and hard on
Supergirl yeah that's the thing you know
the Henry story is so upfront that you
wind up talking about that but let's
just take a step back and say pourquoi
Supergirl like they already have one of
those it's quite good that smells like
they're doing what they did with flash
which is like well that's you know the
TV show we're gonna have our own
Supergirl thing I mean if I'm Greg
Berlanti I'm like you're welcome you
know what I'm saying yeah let me do this
for you
the wonder for them one thing I did here
though was that apparently Brainiac is
gonna be the villain of this Supergirl
movie yeah I mean that's cool what about
Elrond he might be in there I guess
we'll see yeah so that's that's kind of
the story behind the story is that no
Superman movie but Supergirl is removing
folks they want flights and tights they
just don't want that dude and I'm all
for it I'm all for a Supergirl movie but
at the same time I am you know I'm
heading up to make a Supergirl movie
this week it'd be nice if they were like
yeah we're gonna take Melissa but it
doesn't seem like that's a conversation
they should she's fantastic
but it's probably not gonna be the case
I'm not gonna be the case they got an
answer and they didn't do
Grint they're gonna get somebody that's
not Melissa now I wonder if that puts a
ticking clock on the TV show because
they haven't have they ever they had
like you know they've got a flash and
Justice League but they don't have a
movie called the flash while there's a
TV show called the flash right but I
mean if the flash keeps going and the
flash movie is 2019 then at one point
there will be a TV version you could
pick from and a cinematic version you
can pick from which unless Supergirl
ends anytime soon which ratings wise
that doesn't seem to be the case then at
one point there's going to be a
Supergirl TV show on the air and a
completely different Supergirl movie in
the theaters wise or know if you were in
charge would you do that I would not do
that I feel like that's that is offering
people a reason to stay home we're just
like hey if I just want to scratch this
itch of seeing a girl in a miniskirt and
a cape fly around I get it here for free
every week or if I want to see the guy
in the red outfit run real fast to solve
all his problems I could do it right
here
yeah so do you think then reverse
engineering this conversation that they
canceled the shows before those movie
started they couldn't do that
they still make money I mean they're two
different in completely different
divisions one is Warner TV and they
output through CW and stuff and they go
by a completely different model it's
based on the commercial model
advertising and now I guess they
couldn't but seems weird to have two of
the same out there it does its
marketplace confusion you know it's it's
which one I want to go see Supergirl
which one where why okay why are you
choosing that one I don't know it's
bigger I guess yeah I don't quite get it
and there's too much money in the TV
shows there's over the course of
Supergirl over the course of the flash
will make more money than a single one
of those movies will probably actually
get to sell it over and over again to a
bunch of countries and it's more than
one movie it's like here's 22 hours per
season here's a couple [ __ ] seasons
yeah I mean
that's billions of dollars if those
things are hit which they are the
hardcore loyal Berlanti verse fan and/or
employee and me doesn't you know is like
oh man why would you do that
but the comic book aficionado in me is
like we're gonna have a Super Girl movie
with Brainiac in it so I'm of two minds
of the subject I'd like it a lot more if
they use the Supergirl that I'm familiar
with but you know doesn't seem like
that's gonna be the case they've not
said anything either way but if it's
anything like the flash movie right then
they're just heading in their own
direction yeah so back to Henry he's out
of a job but not out of a job because
he's on that show the Netflix show The
Witcher everybody talked about it here
he maybe he knew something that we
didn't know apparently he did bad early
on and then he put up a video on
Instagram yesterday with Blue Danube
playing and he was wearing a Krypton
phys ed shirt and then he lifted a
Superman doll into the frame and never
said anything and then lowered it it was
like something out of a [ __ ] David
Lynch movie I'm not quite sure what it
was about but I don't know and the
caption was something like today was
interesting or something so I don't I
don't know if that's him going yeah I'm
not playing Superman anymore or if he's
going no I'm still Superman or he's a
hostage I should be looking for the
blinks this proof of life all right so
yeah that's big shake-up for the DC
movie universe but at the same time not
so big a shake-up it's just more really
confirmation of what we all assumed is
that they're not interested in making
another superman movie at this point or
another Justice League movie as we know
it yeah it's true you know well we knew
that the moment the movie came out we
could all pretty much assume they were
done there but they've got a robust
schedule coming man Aquaman looks
[ __ ] amazing
Wonder Woman or is it 1984 or 85 84
Wonder Woman 84 [ __ ] we soon will be
seeing I'm
an image of Kristen Wiig dressed as
cheetah that's gonna be fantastic and
another reason to stay alive in this
horrible world there's some good and
that Shazam trailer it looks more and
more charming every time I watch it I
mean but I'm real [ __ ] mad that would
have been a cool cameo to have [ __ ]
Superman pop in at the end he's like
you're a Superman and like tie the
university other there's there's a great
beat in the comic I'm not entirely sure
where it comes from I've just seen these
pages online of when Superman goes to
the Wizard to inquire why the [ __ ] you
would do this to a boy because Superman
of course gives a [ __ ] about Billy
Batson like why would you make this
ten-year-old boy act like an adult
why don't you let him be a boy why are
you gonna burden a child with this much
power and this much of a secret he was
like well the magic has rules it's like
I've heard enough of your [ __ ] rules
like that's a child and you're
endangering a child and that kid is
alone and he's scared and then the next
scene and the Wizards like go talk to
Batman [ __ ] but then the next
scene is is super as Clark Kent finds
Billy Batson in the [ __ ] like
tenement building he's squatting in
because again he's a [ __ ] orphan
mm-hmm and he goes sits down next to him
and you know Billy's little [ __ ]
jittery and is like listen I know what
it's like to have a secret that you
can't tell anybody if you ever want to
talk if you ever need anybody to lean on
if it's ever too much for you you can
talk to me he's like why the [ __ ] should
I trust you and then he opens his shirt
and just shows the Superman logo and
it's like if that was that [ __ ] cameo
then I'm sad it couldn't happen you just
made me cry god that's that's really
[ __ ] beautiful it's like the the
righteous anger of a god upset at the
the the endangering of a child it's kind
of lovely yeah you didn't hear the Teen
Titans I guess
[Music]
well alright selective amnesia enough
about henry cavill man what's next
you've heard of this this young
filmmaker Jordan Peele yes he is
choosing the next consolation in which
he's gonna get involved in and he seems
to have set his eyes on Candyman oh yeah
Tony Todd movie with Tony Todd movie was
that a Clive Barker thing or no never it
was I believe why Barker thing based on
it was 1992 that movie was but it's
super I mean knowing what the the
because I forgot I haven't seen it movie
if I remember correctly he was it took
place in the Cabrini Green tenements
Illinois in Chicago and he was kind of
like the Bloody Mary right if you say
his name three times he appears right
but Candyman was an artist and son of a
slave who had his hand severed and been
murdered by bees because that happens oh
that's right there were bees involved
yeah that sounded more like a note from
a like a [ __ ] studio meeting like my
kid got stung by a bee the other day and
it [ __ ] really killed man put bees in
the movie what if the bees formed a
giant spider John Peters but yeah like
that's like if that's the origin story
of that guy next slave murdered by the
father of a former lover and hand
severed and and lynched is now haunting
this [ __ ] place and you say his name
three times he comes in exact vengeance
timely timely and that's very from the
maker of get out yeah I get that yeah
makes sense good pairing yeah so he
hasn't signed on yet but he's he's
circling and interested and he's also
making a Twilight Zone show at some
point and he's currently shooting his
new movie us which nobody knows anything
about and also wasn't he doing some with
JJ yeah Lovecraft
County yeah so yeah he's busy he's the
kind of busy that you get when you
giant hit and people offer you shouldn't
you say yes and he's also creative it
always has been right so it's like right
in his wheelhouse now people are coming
to him instead of him going like hey
could you help me with this so good for
him yeah that sounds good I'd see that
totally and the last thing I have is
that yesterday I think well maybe it's
Tuesday I can't remember how DVD
releases go anymore but they pushed it
to Fridays did they I don't know
so lo came out oh this this week did it
already yeah oh [ __ ] digitally
that's right so it's not on blu-ray set
but you could watch online you can watch
on that too oh [ __ ] I know what I'm
doing tonight and the co screenwriter
John Kasdan went on Twitter Lawrence
Kasdan's kid Lawrence Kansas kid and
posted 52 useless solo factoids and
tidbits for anyone who's interested I'm
interested I know
so we will not read all 52 of them some
of them are just like we like this
location because we wintered up there is
the Kasden family so we wanted to make
it kind of wintery oh that's kind of
sweet so you're right we don't have to
show that you can read that the rest of
that online you're picking the gold I'm
sure I've picked the gold like no one
he's like here's some you didn't know
people didn't like this movie I did
though I enjoyed so I look forward to
watching it again him meat and chewy is
a fantastic scene worthy of any Star
Wars movie in the entire Canon like it's
their their Darth Vader rogue one scene
of that movie is Han meeting - it's
really wonderful fancy you say that
number 13 on the list Miller and Lord
had the idea that Chewie would be the
Beast a punishment for disobedience
soldiers and I suppose droids on min ban
they also have the brilliant idea to at
hyung at the crucial moment speak
shrilly wook that came from Lord and
Miller and they kept that in the movie
the mud pit is pure Lord Miller and for
my money it's one of the best scenes in
the movie it is it really is that's Wow
and that's generous of him as the
screenwriter to give that
up to so what he's saying is the two
boys who made you know the 21 Jump
Street movies and the Lego the brilliant
lego movie they originally made a solo
and then they got fired and then Ron
Howard remade it but apparently that
sequence remains intact and that was
their idea instead as a great [ __ ]
scene and it's cool where he speaks
wookie at one point you're like oh
they're gonna be friends number 10
Lawrence Kasdan and I he abbreviates LK
that's supposed to dad which he could
also do dad because we get it right and
I fought long and hard for Hans stint
and expulsion from the Imperial Academy
we felt it was crucial to see him
trained as a pilot ultimately though it
was always a hindrance to the flow of
the story which consistently felt like
it didn't really take off until Chewie
arrived in the movie I don't I don't
know if I agree that the movie doesn't
take off to Chewie gets there but I
until you mentioned that he was an
imperial soldier I completely forgot
about that aspect of the story so he's
right it didn't really do much we go
straight to him being in war
apparently post Academy right I would
like to see that yeah him trained bad it
wasn't a bad color to throw into the
story of Han Solo
like he was trained by Imperials but
there was also something kind of nice
about you know hey man I don't go in for
any of that [ __ ] like from the first
Star Wars movie but you know I see how
it makes sense they try to tie it in in
retrospect
Tandy Newton may actually have been too
good and too interesting Wow Tandy
Newton she was too good or too
interesting as vow as Woody Harrelson's
girlfriend compatriot because they
killed her is that why it was always in
the design of the story that Beckett
would lose his trusted crew members
during the conve XJ awn wrong and be
forced to rely on newbies han and chewie
and this would also open the door for
Lando kira and l3 to join the crew but
Andy is so compelling to watch that the
death of her character feels like it's
sheet it's an odd and unexpected problem
that comes with working with such
amazing compelling actors and
universe you just want more of them I
guess it might also just be like hey
it's her from Westwood and she's gone
you know so you know it's like seeing
somebody you're like alright they're
cast for a reason but then they don't
really kind of let them be the star of
the show might have been better to I
mean she did a great job in that role
but I think his problem or the problem
he's talking about the interesting
problem would have been easier the
easiest solved if somebody an unknown
have played that role but since you put
somebody in the role that everybody
knows particularly from a show that's
very popular right now
I guess people like a man she can go out
on fire and separate that was something
we were talking about after the predator
sterling K Brown like a spoiler but he
goes out in the movie and a weird well I
guess that is a spoiler whoops but he
goes out in a really like wait is that
guy gone is it over like he's just not
here anymore
yeah it was kind of kind of fast uh 25
at this point it goes without saying but
Donald Glover was born to play Lando I
remember the thrill of seeing his screen
test then the thrill of watching Bob
Iger and alan horne
watch his screen test all of us knowing
how much fun it was going to be and he
would steal each and every scene was in
this was before atlanta or awaken my
love but after community in my opinion
donald needs to Don the Cape again and
the sooner the better
I mean look I'd agree with him I'd watch
the Lando movie but I watched the solo
movie the problem was not a lot of
people watched it with me so but he
seems to have a great many fans I mean
[ __ ] let him direct the movie or let
whoever directed the videos is last two
videos direct the movie yes they
certainly know how to catch attention
yeah but it's always fascinating to me
when people get cast before they did the
things we think they're famous for mmm
like Hemsworth was cast for [ __ ] was it
Star Trek no cabin in the woods before
he was a thing of the four Star Trek
before Star Trek and way before Thor but
JJ had never seen cabin in the woods
when he cast him for for Trek it was
just like oh this guy I guess he's good
bring him by suppose we'll take a look
at him and then oh [ __ ] that guy's a
[ __ ] hero
he should be George Kirk absolutely
should be George
with no none of the other [ __ ] that we
had in our background go into it just he
looks good that's crazy like Donna
Glover
I guess he's funny and handsome maybe I
guess is were wonderful and I'm never
having seen Atlanta where he's
phenomenal so pre that show yeah back to
the list back to the list number 32 the
Maelstrom this is another idea that's
stuck from the first draft trying to
solve the problem of how to make the
Kessel run visually interesting
inventive and at least somewhat logical
weighed heavy on all of us throughout
the process it was something we
discussed endlessly and knew he would
never satisfy everyone and specifically
never satisfying Neil deGrasse Tyson no
we wanted a Jules Verne flavor and we
loved the idea of a storm in space and
what that might look like the Hubble
image of the pillars of creation was a
huge influence in the concept Island two
tests in which there were slow with her
blow-up canisters the debris color
powder and photographed the explosion
the slow-mo blah blah blah blah blah I I
did not think the Kessel run was
visually interesting that's just me I
also I remember them saying Kessel run
but I don't remember the particulars I
will when i rewatch it tonight but
that's a didn't it didn't lodge in my
memory I was there a storm there was a
yeah it was a big [ __ ] tunnel of
clouds and [ __ ] and once you got out of
that tunnel there were like planets just
smashing into each other and giant
octopus creatures living in the storm
maybe that's vague it has a vague memory
but I have a vague memory but also
sounds like Galactus in that Fantastic
Four movie just like he's a bad cloud
yeah so they somehow rendered the Kessel
run to something you don't even remember
seeing yeah but to be fair right that
was always gonna be tough to match what
your imagination for whatever that what
you've heard that term your whole life
and you never saw the Kessel run and so
is tough hurdle to clear you know gone
like wow alright I guess that works
wasn't bad though I wasn't like oh my
god they butchered they pissed on but I
wasn't abortion that scene was not at
all it was totally fine but it doesn't I
don't remember much
number 37 when the movie have made more
money if it had just been 2 hours of
Lando dictating his memoirs to his
hollow recorder perhaps you live and you
learn
he wrote that yeah 39 I wish there was a
special feature where you see Beckett
toss the sized the tantal armor and
gundarr tusks mask he uses as a disguise
on Kessel then just settle into a
time-lapse shot of that gear lying in a
closet in the Falcon for like 15 years
until Lando picks it up and wears it as
a disguise for himself at Jabba's palace
and if you're wondering why are
objecting to how interconnected the
movie is with the others is because that
kind of not that's the kind of nonsense
I think about I like that moment I
thought it was cool when he had the
skiff card elf I totally didn't notice
it I did when I saw it in the theater I
was it go oh [ __ ] there's Lando's outfit
number 41 does the movie work I'm not
the person to ask but here's what I
think does work the moment when Han
jumps into the pilot seat of the Falcon
for the first time it's directed
beautifully Alden nails every moment and
look and unless you're actively
resisting it
John Powell's perfect cue will make your
heart swell that moment is as good as
this movie gets in my opinion
I mean sure but I don't like it doesn't
I don't remember that as much as I
remember hand meeting Chewie Orhan
meeting Chewie you do you remember this
moment I do and it works it does work
well to me not I'm gonna say not much in
the movie does work because when we
talked about I said no it's a perfectly
serviceable movie hmm there are moments
in it that I love I don't particularly
remember that one is one of them but I'm
going yeah [ __ ] it that's cool right
oh let's see but but but the bum for
number 47 in minute how many of these
t52 [ __ ] in many
and they're long in many drafts of the
script emphasis number two was Bosque
who abandoned her at the end of the
movie as he is truly a soldier fortune
this was another thing I fought long and
hard to keep but it was ultimately
overruled
why who overruled it maybe it's dad
they reference Bosque at one point yeah
cool especially because you could pull
that character off like you know it was
a mask so it's not like you know oh we
got the guy who played boss but he's 92
like you just put that [ __ ] reptile
mask on somebody anybody's there 51 if
you felt like it was just a cheap stunt
and I suppose that's fair but the truth
is Darth Maul was built into the design
of solo and many subtle ways I didn't
think it was a cheap stunt I liked it
yeah yeah the bigger is cheap
the name crimson dawn the artifacts and
Dryden study and curious use of teras
kasi Kansas pronounced a right
Maul is my favorite character from the
prequel trilogy I love the day Fulani
brought him back and expanded on a story
in Clone Wars and rebels I love that
there is at least some continuity
between the shows and the movies for me
Maul was designed to pass through solo
as the ultimate Star Wars Kaiser Soze
huh yeah yeah I mean I like that he was
in there he was the big bang like he's
the boss her boss right at the end of
the day and I liked what he said too
about like it's it's one of the only
things that ties the shows and the
movies together yeah yeah I go at that
point
I like seeing him I was confused when I
first saw it but then knocking not
through the whole movie when he first
popped up I'm like wait a second where
does this take place in the timeline and
then my brain filled in the rest gone oh
they're pulling this from the cartoons
and I was like oh [ __ ]
finally will there ever be a sequel
because it seemed it really seems like
you guys were setting one up to be
honest I think the challenge is much
more to do with the foreign box-office
in the u.s. box office personally I
think there are great Star Wars movies
to be made that don't need to cost quite
so much hopefully that will be the trend
in the years to come and maybe just
maybe not trying to allow us one way or
another to tell more stories with Alden
junus Amelia and
with those actors in lawn Howard I would
jump at the opportunity given the way
Hollywood and the culture at large seem
to run from anything labeled a
disappointment the odds seem that
they're against it happening anytime
soon
but I suppose Han wouldn't have it any
other way he's a ray of sunshine isn't
he
well that was good man I've been good
for him for jumping to jumping on line
and being like here's my brain dump on
solo you live with a movie and it sounds
like he's been living with it for a
while and then it goes out there in the
world you've got all this excess
information stuff it's good that he
shared it with folks good that he put it
out there yeah you want to read the rest
of them they're all up on John Kasdan on
Twitter I'm good I read all 52 but I
will watch that movie tonight REE watch
it now knowing a few of these things as
well it was good I thought it was a good
time a [ __ ] it'll be a fun watch at
home I have a bet you people are a lot
more forgiving about it might be all
right so that's it so now we're done
with the news we are indeed give it up
for mark he gave it a new okay man now
we come to the other part of the show
the important part Before we jump into
that though everybody here who came
today got these little keychains I just
want to tell you where that came from
there's a lovely little letter that
accompanied them which voice you're
gonna read this in Bane okay excellent
- JC had covered it mark congratulations
on your recent projects we love your
podcast in your recent work on both
Halloween and castle rock we make heart
I can't keep doing them we make
handcrafted personalized gifts and we're
trying to further our dream so we made
some free gifts for you to give out we
thought you could give them out to
celebrate the new title of the podcast
we put SBC for the scum and villainy
Cantina on the thing as well we would
love it if you gave us a shout out or
just had some goodies to give out we are
huge fans of the show and thank you so
much Lisa and Tony from is that Stanley
winked is that the name of their company
so if you're walking away with a yes
Stanley Stanley winked the good folks at
Stanley winked made the little keychains
man you go visit them at Facebook thank
you guys for for sending Lisa and Tony
very school okay now we get to the
second part of the show the most
important part of the show man this is
the QA part of the show man the QA is
where we open it up to a few folks in
the audience and you take the show in
the directions you want to go and
hopefully we can follow along or provide
some [ __ ] answers this week as every
week Deacon Bret deke and our good
friend who works at 4dx has given us
tickets to a 40 X to 5 sets of tickets
to go see a movie in the 40x of
presentation they got one at LA Live you
could use the theater there to see it
it's amazing I talk about it every
[ __ ] week if you've never seen a
movie in 40x
take time go see it pick a big expensive
movie the big expensive ones like work
best and stuff don't go see like clerks
that'd be a waste of time in the movie
if there's snow and it snows in the
movie theater and you
as though if the cameras doing this [ __ ]
your chair is doing this [ __ ] it's
pretty wonderful it's great experience
so we thank them every week man give
them a some applause for DX but in
addition to that as previously mentioned
the good folks at DC to celebrate Batman
day has given us five copies of the DC
anatomy of a metahuman it's inside
edition's published it they make all
those beautiful books inside edition's
makes like gorgeous geek books this book
is so heavy there he is right there it's
so heavy you could kill a human being
with this book it could be used for home
defense and stuff like that so we're
gonna give out those books we got one
two three four five so what you're gonna
win if you question is good enough is a
copy of this book and a set of tickets
two tickets go see 40 X movie what the
[ __ ] kind of prize package is that man
it's wonderful okay our QA we have one
simple rule man the question has to
apply to us both you can't get up and
ask me like what would Jay and Silent
Bob think about this or that because
then Mark can't play so it's it's always
more fun if we're talking about general
stuff that doesn't have to do with what
we specifically do for a living because
then we can get to geek out on the
answer but that's it the rule is the
question has to be answerable by both me
and mark you get that question right
you're gonna win a set of tickets and
this gorgeous gorgeous [ __ ] book man
so JC the proprietor of this here bar
and space because the guy who goes into
the audience to find our question asker
he's got the first one he's placing them
into the position what's your name young
sir I'm Jeff everyone give it up for
Jeff
jefe
the room is yours what do you want to
know well mark castle rock we just
watched the last episode that last night
it was amazing oh thank you very much
thank you for that I had so much to do
with it well but your episode was great
- that was episode six work do you work
on all of them like are you guys in a
room you're pitching ideas like with
some of your ideas in the final episode
yes
yeah there's DNA I didn't ask you if you
come Don it I just [ __ ] asked
oh no that's our writers rooms word
sticky awful sticky so it's like a
Beatles hangout they with one story he's
changed the Beatles forever man
ones like come together you know you
could have just died with that nobody
needed to know it's true okay
yeah well in Kevin you've always been
such an inspiration such an
inspirational guy my lady's name is
Jennifer I we started a podcast years
ago and this is just like a weird little
mini question but a big inspiration was
you and your Jennifer dude what is she
coming back she won't do it I'd ask her
all the time she said she would do an
episode of SModcast with main stuff but
she doesn't wanted new podcasts it was
so good tell her that we miss her
it was honestly like that was the one
podcast I felt like where I was closest
to who I am in real life there's very
little presentation put on and stuff a
very little thought to be like be the
Entertainer it was just like I'm just
gonna be me with her the way we always
are so I I enjoyed doing as well maybe
one day I could talk her back into it
but so far no go alright well so the
real question alright so in a few days
same birthday as Adam West actually I'm
happy to say I turned 40 - hey and every
time I say 40 - because I'm a big dork I
always think of Hitchhiker's Guide to
the galaxy which is great fiction and
then a few years ago they made a movie
which had the most amazing cast
like everything going for it but they
deviated so much from the book by the
end that it was just kind of yeah yeah
so I was just wondering in that vein
like either something you've seen it's
an adaptation that you just would have
done wildly differently or is there
something you'd like to adapt knowing
full well that you could take this thing
you love but you'd still have to change
it to make it like cinematic what would
you do
[Music]
I I will go the adaptation that I saw
and thought that there was so much more
potential for that I didn't see on the
screen the Dark Tower oh yeah yeah they
they made one amazing decision in
yourself as a gunslinger and then made
every bad decision after that every
place that could have made a left in to
Providence they made a right turn into
the [ __ ] and it's but there's also a
world in which I get why like they made
it away a movie ultimately maybe like a
boy in his gunslinger where the book is
a gunslinger yeah show me show me the
[ __ ] gun son you do and gonna sling
you things I don't really care that much
about this kid in New York I don't care
that much about I got these problems I
got a saw but I have my Pitt gunslinger
with me in Manhattan like I don't get
why you do that just make make the
[ __ ] book like that's one of those
where the book is great it's daffy and
it's insane and it's it's wildly
speculatively fictional it's it's all of
the things that you kind of love and
they made a movie that wasn't any of the
things that anybody loved except for in
yourself so yeah I would I would take
another crack at that if I could and you
could build a whole universe on it yeah
because there is one I have a little
experience of that so yeah let me see I
mean there's answers up like and this
ain't I waited my whole life to see a
Superfriends movie and you know I kind
of got one and just asleep
and you know it was fine but like I
would like given a chance I'd like to
see another Justice League movie but I'm
not gonna pick that one let me see
well we were just talking about solo I
think it's solo movie I think a stand
Elijah Lowe absolutely could have made a
bunch of money at the box office if it
was solo vs. Boba Fett and so I'm not
but I'm not picking that that's for
somebody else to do I'm gonna pick and
this is me all right
i'ma pick Howard the Duck Howard the
Duck we all know and respect or abhorred
the movie and stuff we know it exists
thank God there was a comic book movie
made at the time but it wasn't the
Howard the Duck that we knew from the
comic books so I think there's
definitely a truer version of that
character to do particularly now
particularly in a world where everybody
knows all the Marvel characters you
don't even have to have them involved
I'm not saying like [ __ ] crossover
with everybody but like he lives he's
the epicenter of the Marvel Universe so
you get to make [ __ ] references
galore and now everybody's in on those
references it's no longer just like only
hardcore comic book and aficionados
would know your mother would understand
the [ __ ] jokes that Howard the Duck
could make now about the Marvel Universe
and also Howard was like you know
trapped in a world they never made like
he could be a wry observer of the
culture particularly right [ __ ] now I
just think you could really do a great
version of our the duck would you give
him a sex scene
the original had that in case no one's
see I mean yeah well it didn't
technically have a sexy and has seen
where she Beverly found a duck condom
which was really like weird but it was
right as like AIDS was becoming a
national crisis and so safe sex was a
conversation and they stuck it into this
movie but it did create implications
like most people think of that movie -
like in that movie where that chick
[ __ ] a donkey that's not what happened
at all they're very good friends but I
would I include a sex scene yes just not
with Beverly but that's I was a great
question and that gets [ __ ] a book
it's a tickets well done man you're
gonna take your Jenny out on a date and
you're gonna sit there and read a book
to her in the movie theater well done
all right JC take us someplace was your
name boyfriend or big Fred big fans so
we had all the time about random comic
things or movie things and so recently
we decided to pick a character that we
thought would best represent us but
character as well so like as a character
and would through their characteristics
and stuff and we picked a funny for each
other and I found out that he thinks I'm
very cold apparently he picked killer
frost for me so I'm apparently smart and
very dark and cold and so we found out a
lot what did you pick for him you're
like Jesus pick something funny for him
too because we also did movies as well
and I told him when he gets into like a
repetitive mode I think of like
10-second Tom from the with the first
date and every time you start singing
something on a loop or he'll even start
singing like you're like a smoke smoke
so just repeat it over
over again so we'd gets into that mode
I'm like you're like just repeat stuff
man so I would say my question is is if
you two were to pick characteristic wise
a movie a character from a comic a movie
and a TV show for each other just to
show each other how you think about each
other and maybe for yourself but like
obviously like you know if you think
he's smart and funny you would pick a
character like that or if you think he's
just a smart ass like Deadpool you would
pick a character for that like so what
character would you pick for each other
number one before we even get into it
that wins you get a booking tickets well
done
[Applause]
okay now to actually provide an answer
do the service from which we were I know
well it's [ __ ] breathtakingly good do
you have one
not yet me neither honestly my first
instinct and then I was like don't go
with it was to be like Alfred but uh cuz
you're like smart and like really not
British yeah but but that's so so white
let me let me let me thank all right oh
I got yours okay I think I have yours
okay ready yeah should we write it down
so we can't change it behind each
other's backs like if I say a really
flattering one you're like oh [ __ ] well
I was gonna pick [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
Lockheed the Dragon for you but instead
now I'll pick this should we write him
down so he can't see what I I solemnly
swear that I will not change all right I
solemnly swear I'll go first
ready go first Reed Richards right when
you think about it you're like yes he
has a little white in his hair
[Applause]
mark is so smart so good at stories so
good at putting things together man
that's who I think I've read Richard
smartest guy in the [ __ ] room and
like Reed Richards while Reed Richards
leads the Fantastic Four it doesn't feel
the need to lead he's so busy building
being smart he's not like hey man I'm
[ __ ] necessarily in charge here and
stuff like that he can he can top from
the bottom that was just a real insight
into our relationship wasn't it
do you want to go see another movie all
right Richard zoom I'm Reed Richards you
are Don Quixote oh wait I'll follow you
keep going if you're Sancho Panza it's
okay but but you're a dreamer who
believes in the in the sanctity of the
dream who believes that it is worth if a
thing is worth doing it's worth doing to
the ends of the earth and whatever that
dream might be even if it's dusk
with that sometimes the dream is is the
thing that drives not the not the goal
yeah so yeah it's the romantic dreamer
of it all I buy that that's sweet man
thank you
what a great question
all right JC give us another victim we
got three books and three sets of
tickets man what's your name they're
young camper hi my name is Matt I'm from
England
matt is from England give it up for Matt
and that's in the box
I am hey I thought you might have been
from the Bronx not quite the same accent
because they make me different from the
Bronx so I came on the way here to do
two things one I did the other day I
proposed to my girlfriend okay this is
pretty great
it was on the if I do say so myself
just review your own story it was on the
steps of the clock tower the Back to the
Future clock town that is [ __ ] good
that's good and I'll give you the time
of your life she had no idea and it was
awesome and just as we leave him with
just phone and a bunch of friends sent
him and while Emma's on the phone a
[ __ ] DeLorean rolls around the corner
and parks up in front of the clock tower
we're like is this happening no I didn't
arrange this but we gotta go back it was
incredible they turn into [ __ ]
it turned out to be some dude who just
built his own DeLorean and I brought it
there to take a picture and arranged
that exact time to turn up so we're like
man I would have been like I paid for
that I love you that much let's wet the
other reason obviously was to see you
guys say thank you very much for all
you've done okay so my question I want
you guys to go back to your early 20s
and switch roles no switch career paths
even so mark what I really want to ask
is like what would your version of
clerks be even if the next part of the
question is and Kevin what time do you
want to die tonight you're still winning
man that's that's good I can obviously
and what would your Curry career be as a
comic book writer and TV writer how
would you do what would you have done to
clerks what would I have done to clerks
well it would have been set at a bodega
in the Bronx there would have been a cat
there because there's always a cat in
bodegas and I'm not sure why that's not
sanitary
we had a cat okay see Jersey bodegas as
well see bodegas as well where jewel cat
poop on cue I mean we would have got we
were spared no expense on that fun but I
don't think it would have been
manifestly different because he and I
are not that manifestly different anyway
like it still would have been about the
things that you grew up loving that
maybe other people didn't find the same
value in that you did you know and for
me it's also [ __ ] Star Wars and comic
books it's also all of that nurtured
kung fu movies and kiss I loved kiss
when I was like nine years old for
really simple reasons is
they looked [ __ ] awesome no I never
listen to kiss I just kept looking at
kiss and that's enough you put that on
the best of KISS album set you're gonna
have to listen that look in that it's
enough
I met gene Simmons because uh because my
buddy Adam Freeman who I co-wrote genius
with used to produce the gene Simmons
Family Jewels show on A&E so one day is
like hey we needed some extras for the
shoot at there at the Simmons house do
you want to come it's like I'm gonna if
you're gonna let me come and meet
[ __ ] gene Simmons so I pull up to
this [ __ ] giant palatial mansion in
the Hollywood Hills and in case you
didn't notice on the show there is an
entire room a vast cavern of a room in
that house devoted to kiss and that they
have one piece of every single piece of
kiss merchandise including the coffin
including the coffin in this [ __ ]
room and so you know I get to meet
[ __ ] gene and he's super nice and I
don't know why because I'd seem to meet
other people later and he wasn't that
nice but he just started like taking her
comics out of his collection as I hate
you I see this here's old man scenes'
logo from 1946 because I bought it
because I love it and and I told him say
hey me you know like I loved kiss when I
was nine I didn't listen to your music
till I was like thirty he's like alright
that works for me but I don't care how
you got here as long as you got here
alright so yes that is my other the time
I saw him be addicted somebody though
[Laughter]
there's a guy I same print Adam invited
me they were playing Madison Square
Garden so he invited me backstage what
year this would have been 2000 and so
he's in the recent yeah yeah recent
years and so go backstage and you know
meet-and-greet and they're all [ __ ]
dressed up he's the demon he's nine feet
tall whatever and some guy like
insurance salesman from Paramus comes up
it's okay gene I'm not sure if you
remember but we met like four years ago
at a blah blah blah and gene looks at
him sincerely says if you had my life
would you remember you
and I was like hey no just be like nah
man but it's good to see you again easy
it's like if I you had your wouldn't you
remember you know I wouldn't I mean he
is the demon he is the demon he's not
always nice anyway so I don't think we
got to kiss but I guess kid I think you
were gonna put more kiss into clerks
just a poster of Kissin but I think I
don't think they would be that different
I don't think that different maybe less
fellatio jokes maybe more kung fu but
otherwise yeah but it would have been it
would have been brown people in the
Bronx that was my original title for
clerks it should seem little racist so I
change it to clerks well let me see I'm
not gonna pick comic books cuz I've done
comic books - and I won't pick TV I want
to pick the career of marks that I think
I might have actually enjoyed him and
good at mark was an entertainment
journalist for a long long time and you
know ran shops and stuff like that
worked for people and had people working
for him and stuff but at the end of the
day there I I don't know anybody that
does that job that isn't on some level a
fan because you can write about anything
in this world you don't have to write
about the entertainment business but if
you do is because it appeals to you at
the end of the day like we were at one
of my hand to God I even share this with
him I'll share it with him now one of my
favorite moments so far of 2018 was me
and Mark sitting in the movie before it
began just a few hours ago and while we
were watching trailers we were just
talking shop and not even our shop but
while you're sitting there gone like
what was the [ __ ] trailer came up
where I was like well we talking about
predator we're gone how much it cost me
was that we were try to figure it out it
was like 78 or something or 80 million
and I was sitting there gone all right
man
like the head of a studio and shame
blacks like I want to do predator movie
and it was under 100 yeah I didn't
[ __ ] roll those dice and he was like
yeah and then he started talking about
this one my favorite [ __ ] moments of
2018 because that it reminds me of like
sports aficionados they like to sit
around talk about like a human beings
value like oh I'll get through a bird
but he ain't worth that kind of money
and [ __ ] like that and I whenever I hear
people do that I'm like what do you care
you've got no skin in this game but I
was just sitting in a movie theater
going I would greenlight this you know
like a [ __ ] thing right so the idea
of doing entertainment journalism that
would have thrilled me I would love I
mean I kind of do it on the podcast I
sit down with a bunch of different
people and stuff and once or twice I've
done like traditional interviews for
arena magazine back in the day I got to
interview Tom Cruise they sent me an
interview Tom Cruise for The Last
Samurai and so like you know even though
I work in the business like I was like
I'm gonna [ __ ] me Tom Cruise like Oh
crazy so I had all my lists ready to go
a list of questions and I was going in
there I was like I'm not letting this
dude off easy man like you know I'm
gonna give it come and get good [ __ ] out
of him and I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm not
like I'm gonna hold his feet to the fire
and stuff but like I'm gonna ask the
tough questions if I have to instead
they brought me into the room and he
stands up and first words out of his
mouth he goes with that big Tom Cruise
smile ago Silent Bob and that man could
have put his dick in my mouth
oh my god I was like who knows my
characters here so I think I would have
enjoyed that if that like if I didn't
get to make movies I think ultimately I
would have aggregated toward trying it
myself even if I was a journalist if I
was interviewing people I was covering
entertainment I think I would have
aggregated to doing it though because my
makeup my personality I couldn't just
talk about it from so long without
actually giving it a try and I so I
think I would have eventually got to
film but I would have enjoyed
interviewing cats I've always enjoyed
doing it thus far and I think like I
would have enjoyed that aspect of his
career yeah when I got to Entertainment
Weekly it dawned on me very quickly that
everybody there was a fan of something
like you're a fan of soap opera fan of
horror novels were a fan of nerd [ __ ]
you're a fan of you know elo you're a
fan of prog rock whatever it was
everybody there loved something to death
and this is the only way they could get
money they could make money out of that
love was [ __ ] I get to write about I get
to talk about it I get to interview
people about it and they'll pay me for
this this is amazing and it's absolutely
true that there was a segment of that of
especially when I started of people who
loved it so much they eventually went on
to make it because after a while some of
that passion will translate into a
desire to want to be part of the story
Jeff Jensen Jeff Jensen Jeff Jensen was
an e W writer interviewed me a couple
times and he wound up writing
Tomorrowland amongst other things yeah I
worked with Gillian Flynn was on the
staff of VW the same time that I was and
like she was the reason she's now the
reason why nobody there was a write a
novel it was like well where the odds
that they're gonna be two people out of
that like that yearbook who will be
Gillian Flynn who's gonna write gone
girl after that who's gonna do that [ __ ]
I didn't know that she was yes she wrote
for UW and she did she was the TV critic
for a while she was the book editorial
assistant for a while and then she now I
could see it man like the idea of like
if you're the if you're doing TV you're
watching so much [ __ ] story
and as you sit there watching story
you're predicting it as it goes and when
it doesn't go the way you think you've
then got a fresh idea in your head
number one you've got an opinion we were
like they should have done this but then
the smart cracker decides to take that
idea creates something completely new
and go forward okay that makes sense I
could see that it's strange that the job
doesn't lead to more people jumping over
the business you know I just ran into
the other day for the first time in a
while Dan Trachtenberg he directed
Cloverfield Lane but I knew him in a
previous life he was the first person
that ever introduced me to a podcast he
did geek scape I think it was called
geek drone geeked Rome with I think the
other cat's name was Michael London and
so they asked me at one point I forget
how it happened but they came over to
the office where we did clerks - behind
the Henson Studios it was an old Chaplin
bungalow and they brought like this big
recording equipment and sat down to
record a podcast with me and I'd never
been on one and there were these two
kids and I would like the whole time I'm
like you can just do this like you
didn't have to ask your parents or
something like that and there's a pocket
you just do whatever you want say what
everyone so that was the first one I was
on the next one I was on was like my own
so I ran into Dan I did this this movie
kin is out and that for the DVD or the
blu-ray there's an extra about DVD and
blu-ray and laserdisc extras in the past
because there's a whole generation of
filmmakers who now learned watching the
behind the scenes stuff on DVDs back in
the past so they got a little panel
people together to talk about it and he
was there man and he was like hey man
Stan Trachtenberg and I was like oh Dan
Trachtenberg who made you know 10
Cloverfield Lane or whatever [ __ ] I said
hey man how are he's like I haven't seen
you in a while and in my head I'm going
I've never [ __ ] I didn't go to the
premiere I've never have I met this man
and then he goes when we recorded geek
drone that instantly I was like holy
[ __ ] that was you I was like that
changed my life man like at that point
like I stopped making movies it became a
podcaster and then he became a movie
maker
stop doing podcast so his [ __ ] trick
worked man like now that I think about
it he stole my life it was really cool
run into it but he was a guy that was a
journalist who is now a filmmaker so
it's possible to do that thing and love
it so much that you're like alright I
eventually want to do it one day which
is where you are right no but to be fair
you always wanted to do it you were you
were naming it to entertainment
journalism that's just something do
until the other thing it was a parallel
track and I kept on looking over saying
hey all that [ __ ] over there that's what
I want to do and just waiting for the
turn off the expressway to get there
don't tell my old bosses that because
they thought I was invested poetic way
to put it create a real word picture
there well done again that was a great
question you win a book and tickets take
your new fiancee to go see a movie
pleasure man pleasure
alright JC we need another victim we got
two books and two sets of tickets left
what's your name young camper hi I'm
Nick everyone give it up a neck mark I I
just also want to say thank you so much
for Castle Rock it was amazing I loved
it I can't wait to keep seeing more from
you from your future projects that's
very kind of you Kevin I owe you a great
deal thanks I actually proposed to my
wife on your show comic book men oh the
happiest day in my life was that the
episode tell him Jim Lee yes I remember
like Walter who is not a generally and
emotional guy definitely emotional about
it and I talked to him about because on
that show they would shoot things and
then later on I'd come for the podcast
and the idea was they would tell me what
happened while I wasn't there so as they
were describing the episode on camera
for our show you know I'm engaged and
they're telling me the broad points and
stuff brought shows but then between
tanks they would talk about like you
know in real terms like the my friends
like not just like hey there's cameras
on but like and Walter is like it was
[ __ ] up he's going I got really
emotional I didn't imagine that that
it happened but and I knew it was coming
and still like it really broke me up
inside so if you can find the [ __ ]
human and Walter Flanders well thank you
so my question is for both of you you've
written for many different forms and
mediums of comic books movies TVs
journalism books what has been the most
challenging and also what has been the
most rewarding the most challenging is
yoga it was so hard I got really
emotional ah let me see what's been the
normally I would say the most
challenging and my career has been
working with notes from others I haven't
spent too much time in other people's
yards so to speak I've pretty much done
my own thing my whole career and so
because of that I've never really had to
deal with many notes like you know I'll
seek advice from people I [ __ ] send
him a script all the time be like can
you give me a read and if he's like this
is wrong this is stupid
I go in and [ __ ] change it and stuff
like that but you know I'm not above a
good idea I'm not that stupid but at the
same time I'm like well this is me this
is a statement about Who I am and so
like I'm way invested in it it's it's
making some dream come true it's it's
all it's it's more than just the thing
itself right so I I'm when when it comes
to working on somebody else's thing and
I've done that of many times over my
career that's weirder because then you
have to deal with input from somebody
else and in some cases you have to take
that input in fact in most cases you
have to take it because they're [ __ ]
paying you and so my personality doesn't
really lend well to that traditionally
so in the Pat means see that Superman
story I used to tell all the time that's
a story about somebody giving me notes
and maybe I'm like are you [ __ ] crazy
so I I normally bristle about that
that's my least favorite part of the
process but I will caveat it and say I'm
working on this thing right now his
thing I
talking about that like looks like the
you know it might happen this big
project and and people thought it was a
movie but it's a series and stuff and so
I've been working with a studio because
it's there's it's all there's like none
of this IP is mine the job is wonderful
because it's you're playing with
somebody else's toys and because it's
their toys all the ideas
technically generate from them so it's
it's like being able to work on this
wonderful thing where I can be as
creative as I want and I'm probably
being more creative doing this thing
than I've been in a long [ __ ] time
but at the end of the day like there's
there's I can't make it what it's not I
can't make it mine so to speak
it's definitely theirs and normally in
that process like you know when you get
notes it's like you want to bang your
head against a wall and then you have to
decide how invested you are like when
it's my stuff I'm fully invested and I'm
like I'll go down swinging to keep it
what it should be or whatever when it's
somebody else's thing you're like
alright well I I want to fight for
what's right and what I feel this is
happening in the story particularly as
the writer but at the same time these
are not my toys and since and
technically then hence not my ideas they
were put in place well before me so you
have to do this weird dance of like how
much do I care because if you care too
much then you wind up getting into
fights with the people who you're paying
you and it's one thing to fight about
your own material like well hey man
[ __ ] chasing amy is this is the way
it has to end and this I'll tell you why
but when you're working on somebody
else's thing there's less wiggle room to
be like no it has to be this because
they're like well it wasn't that before
and it hasn't been that for the 50 years
that existed or whoever so you can't
really back it up as much the process
this thing that I've been working on
lately though hands down has been so
much fun dealing with the studio aspect
of it the people that give me notes the
development team on it I maybe it's
because I'm [ __ ] getting older in
life or maybe it's because like the
[ __ ]
I don't know what but I've had a [ __ ]
blast I look forward to going in to the
notes session because every time we've
done it the project has gotten better
and I loved the project to begin with
and whatnot and I put a lot of love into
it and they dug it and I got a job and
then you kept working on shaping it and
shaping it and stuff but this team that
I'm working with is for individuals that
this company are so gifted and creative
and at one point like I'm not used to
that when I used to deal with suits it
was they weren't creative in the least
apparently in the time that I've been
gone since I've worked with studios and
stuff like it's been like a minute over
ten years since I've been my other than
doing the Supergirl and flash and stuff
I'm really been in studio world
apparently what they did was they've
they've started hiring writers to be the
executives so it's not just like some
[ __ ] suit who went to law school
who's gone like well I don't know make
it a boy or something like that it's
people that know how to tell stories so
it's almost like getting into it's like
hanging out with him where he'd pitch an
idea and he's like oh you could do this
and suddenly it gets better
so I've normally Ives that part of the
process is irritated me but it's it's
now but been both historically I've
hated it
but now I literally look forward to
going in because I'm like I know when
we're done with this meeting this
[ __ ] thing's gonna get better and not
just better for the mass audience which
I understand like that's what we're in
the business of please in the audience
but even though it's not my material I'm
telling the story with I still I go at
it the same way I go at my [ __ ] I'm I'm
here to please me it's a very
masturbatory process if I'm if I'm happy
I assume others will be too maybe not
the whole [ __ ] world
although the thing I'm working on is
very much for the whole world so
naturally there's more thought into
although I'm and it's so weird one day I
get to tell you what it is and it all
makes sense I can't wait I can't wait
either and that's and whether it happens
or not I'll be able to say what it is
eventually but right now I can't but
this was a note that I received ready
normally get [ __ ] studio notes like I
told that old Superman story and stuff
like this was a stew
vo node I want you to write Superman and
I don't want to see him in that suit and
I never want to see him fly you know
you're like what and why don't we just
make land man or something like that
this was a note that I just got on on
the last pass the script that I did for
this thing I'm working on can you make
it more Kevin Smith and I was like yes
oh my god yes man like that [ __ ] blew
me away particularly because it's not
anything that you would ever associate
with Kevin Smith normally when people
use like examples of other movies they
like do what they did an Iron Man or
something like that throughout this
process they've been like it should
sound more like you know like Dante when
he's like I'm not even supposed to be
here today and I'm like are you just
talking to me in my language like did
you watch all my movies just so you can
memorize the characters and use them as
notes so that I would understand better
and they're like no that's why we came
toward you in the first place we like
what you do we just want to harness that
engine for this so it's been this
incredibly rewarding process which even
if it died like I said it was talking
the other day I was over at the studio
and [ __ ] the big guy was there and
chit-chatting and stuff and I said look
when I was blown up the kids the
development team I was like these
[ __ ] kids are smart man like each one
of them made this [ __ ] thing better
and I've had a blast working with him
like I've never resented a single
[ __ ] note and even if this [ __ ] dies
today like I this has been worth while
this has been fun and they're like it
any dying today so if it happens I'll be
able to share what it was or what it is
and it's [ __ ] thrilling but more so
than anything else the best most
satisfying part of the process was
finding out like that system that studio
system while I was gone I was in it for
a little bit and then I was off doing my
own thing for a long long time they self
corrected and found a better way to
develop scripts they just bring in
[ __ ] writers and stuff so it's that
used to be my least favorite part of the
process now it's my most favorite part
of the process and I actually look like
I'm I don't look forward to I'm sad
about it coming to an end like we'll
find out soon if this thing is going to
happen
and if it happens then the project
becomes something completely different
and I say goodbye to the development
team and [ __ ] move on and it's gonna
be sad for me to say goodbye to the
development team I almost want to hire
them as writers because they've got
great [ __ ] ideas and stuff but
hopefully they'll stay involved as far
as we go anyway that's a very long
answer to a very short question I turn
it over tomorrow okay so the most
challenging thing I've ever written was
my first comic book because the comic
book script format is [ __ ] weird and
if you're writing full full script if
you're writing page one panel one here's
what happens and then you're doing math
and you're doing layout you're doing
dialogue you're doing structure you're
doing all of these things all at once
and it's alright well how many pages in
this book great how many panels on each
page great how many word balloons in
each panel and like all of this is
thought you have to do to write a thing
and and if you've never done it before
you don't know the or it's [ __ ] that you
think you know because you've read
comics but you don't know they're
actually tools you can deploy like the
page turn like suddenly it's just a
thing you do as a read as a reader of
comics but when you're writing it you're
like all right well we're gonna build to
a bunch of action here and then turn the
page and BAM new information that'll
change everything you read before and
then there's also aspects of it like
alright I've plotted it out so that when
they turn this page it's a [ __ ]
splash page that does all this [ __ ] and
then they're like you forgot about the
ads and you're like [ __ ] change
everything cuz the pages are taken up
yeah but it's it's it's so many
different disciplines at once and you've
never done it it is not crushingly hard
to learn how to do once you do it it to
me once you get it it's great you know
there's there's a thing about writing
comics that's unlike anything else you
write in that a the reader becomes a
very active participant in it because
the readers turn the page they're living
in the gutters they're they're filling
in blanks for you and the the the
distance between you and the reader is
as short as it is
almost any kind of fiction you know
maybe writing a novel that you an editor
and and like the printing press but if
you're doing mass media [ __ ] where
you're writing dialog for pictures or a
visual medium it's you an artist and
editor and a publisher and that's it
five people basically between you and
the reader if we make a TV show if you
make a movie there's hundreds of people
between you and your intended audience
and the message has every chance of
getting [ __ ] up along the way and
you're fighting for every last piece of
everything that you thought was
important you're fighting tooth and nail
for all the time because you've got to
preserve the vision because it's so easy
to go astray comics it's I'm not gonna
say it's impossible for it to go as
straight but you're having a direct
conversation with an audience which is
phenomenal but the most rewarding thing
that I've ever Muslim or warning form
that I work in is is journalism I think
because you can have a conversation with
people about the world that they live in
using pop culture for me as a lens you
know being able to talk about things
like whitewashing being able to talk
about things like you know diversity and
inclusion and and all of those things
using nerd [ __ ] as a bit of a way in so
that we're all talking about the same
thing well speaking the same language
but here are new ideas we can discuss
with a common foundation and it was it
was a bit of a dilemma when I when I got
the offer to join Castle Rock that I had
to leave the LA Times and I did feel for
a beat like I'm doing important work
here like I'm having conversations that
The Times has never had that we as a
culture only beginning to have and I
have a I have a soapbox here that's
reaching people in a platform and with a
reach that I've never had before
am I being irresponsible by chasing
after this [ __ ] up dream of writing
dumb [ __ ] [ __ ] for television when I
could be helping to shape the way people
are thinking about the world around them
via the the culture they intake I
eventually said [ __ ] that I won't go
make TV for money but it's still and I
did and I still get to kind of play in
journalism here and there
so get to write for thr I still get to
this podcast is absolutely a form of
criticism and and exercise well for one
of us the other ones just like I love
everything but being able to have that
same conversation with an audience as I
get to scratch that edge here a lot of
the time but yeah that being able to
talk to people about the [ __ ] that I
love and the way that I look at the
world and how it might be the same or
different from you but how we can still
find a way to share that love and help
navigate a course through is the most
rewarding part of anything that I get to
do and that rewards you with a book and
tickets man oh yeah
all right JC gives another guy what's
your name young carefully I'm Sean
everyone give it up for Sean Sean
wearing a plug an excellent buggin thing
t-shirts question to bring back to
Batman day and launch of Batman or fat
man beyond does that make us beyonders
and you win a prize
so my beautiful wife long actually
logged us into DC Universe like couple
days ago watching Super Friends Legion a
super good up for a few days
Batman braving the bold super or Space
Ghost all this really good stuff they've
got some great content so a couple fat
men ago you guys were talking about
Supergirl or a star girl coming on the
show which I'm pumped about like the
star girl Geoff Johns is taking a
character that he very personal to him
and doing a series right and I was
hanging off my chair waiting if you
could talk about the James Robinson Star
Man series if you have any familiarity
we loved it loved it back in the day it
was such a wonderful run a book he's a
great writer James and that star man
take was pretty fascinating pretty
interesting and you know it that
character was always a little bit the
original incarnation of the character
the Silver Age the incarnation of the
character a little on the goofier side
that that incarnation the one that James
did actually
it fairly believable and whatnot and it
was also the second-generation story
like it if I remember my star man
correctly begins with the other son his
brother taking over the mantle but then
he dies like piece 2h 2 of the first
issue and then the brother who was like
I don't have any interest in this [ __ ]
winds up taking over and becoming star
man they should totally do that they
should really like DC should pull that
out and make that this is a pretty great
series market is that what the question
well no no it's a twofer but I was just
indulge me I also liked it yeah so
here's my question okay bring back to
Batman day so now I like I have a stack
of Kevin Smith Side comics which is my
new like gem of my comic collection oh
thank you what is like the gem of your
comic collection either like an issue or
a whole run like I'm also a huge Star
Man fan so like I have that whole comic
rhyme so like what's your comic book gem
that is a great question let me think
what is my back in the day it was easy
to answer like oh I got a giant-size
x-men annual like so back that was the
crown jewel of my collection now let me
think what do I have that I love the
absolute most you got one yeah I mean
it's it's it's a book I haven't read in
for a verb but I loved it to death when
it first came out is I have like a
second printing
I think of Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
number one oh really yeah even the
second print of that is worth money yeah
it's it's not it's not it's it's no
insignificant book yeah but I love that
[ __ ] book when it came out because a
I love ninjas because ninjas are awesome
and I loved sort of anthropomorphic [ __ ]
because secret of NIMH and Disney is
awesome if you're gonna tell me that
talking animals are also ninjas
that's the peanut butter and chocolate
or [ __ ] comic books right
and so and so yeah I remember buying
that because I went to the comic book
store in the town I grew up in Baldwin
Long Island after we left the Bronx
because there were no comic stores in
the Bronx called The Incredible pulp and
hence called the incredible pulp
yeah that's a good name not bad right
and so the guy who owned it was a total
miser and miscreant but kind of like
kids so he would always say like hey kid
here's comics you should read this this
people seem to like this and he pointed
out TMNT number one I was like [ __ ] all
right I'll give it a go sure and took it
home and fell in love with it totally
fell in love with it and I haven't read
a turtle's comic in a long time because
doesn't feel like a story that requires
40 years of telling to be told but in
the beginning it was it was my jam for
real
especially because it was so tied into
daredevil yeah like foot yeah The Foot
Clan instead of the Han Klan and the
turtles became the Turtles because of
the radioactive isotope that Matt
Murdock pushes the man out of the way
that fell down the sewer and that
created the turtles so I remember like
when before the turtles belong to kids
they belong to like hardcore comic book
fans who were like oh my god these guys
tied into [ __ ] daredevil that's sweet
yeah it was bloody as [ __ ] like it was
very serious yeah okay let's see what do
I have that's there's a hallway in my
house that's down by my in-laws rooms a
room on the first floor where we went
into the storage fairly recently and
found all this [ __ ] artwork that had
been taken off the walls of the smog
castle a couple years back and then also
up at City walk we were doing spoilers
there so a lot of artwork was up there
and when it got closed down the artwork
went to one of the storage bins and
stuff so I found it recently I was like
[ __ ] this is we should bring this [ __ ]
on this belongs in a museum and so
normally I keep [ __ ] from my work off
the walls of the house like you walk in
my house we got like a lot of walls
there's
family wall going up all the stairs and
it pretty much depicts our life as a
family media and the kid or parents and
stuff my parents but I don't really like
have clerks this or anything hanging
around a shift for years I didn't do
that
so when I brought all the ship back from
storage I'm like you know I'm more I am
way comfortable with who I am and where
I am in my career and [ __ ] it's time to
put this [ __ ] up on the wall some of
this shit's great so we recently put up
this whole wall of pages from runs of
books that I've worked on so you walk it
down this hallway and there's a full
wall of Aquaman from my green arrow run
and black manta that whole like five
pages telling that story and on the
other side is all the Doctor Strange
stuff from my daredevil run where he's
talking to Mephisto
so as you walk down the hallway like or
as I walk down the hallway and I see it
and I turn I think like there's Aquaman
who's like you know [ __ ] about to
have a big-ass movie and there's Doctor
Strange who was just in a big-ass movie
and you got to play with him [ __ ]
twenty years ago like long before
everyone thought they were cool and it
just makes me it reminds me of the
Garage Band fan to me that's just like I
was in doc oh man before Momoa
[ __ ] you know so I like those
but that's from my own personal
collection so it's little braggy and
stuff but that is a comic book thing the
absolute door I have Dark Knight Returns
in two beautiful French editions that
I've always [ __ ] loved same book but
it's all in [ __ ] French and they're
oversized that I wouldn't even put up on
the top of the list I think about to
pick anything I mean I do have an entire
store so I could be like why the secret
stash of course but there is a single
page that hangs in my office now
something on the wall that doesn't have
to do with me now everything in the
walls in my office is like [ __ ] I've
done and stuff but there's one comic
book page from Alan Moore's Swamp Thing
run and it's from the anatomy lesson
issue which is perhaps one of the
greatest single pieces of comic book
literature
produced it's a [ __ ] magic it's
alchemy it's Alan Moore taking you know
a an alright character good character
created by Bernie writes and stuff so
he's got some good roots to him pun
intended
taking that swamp thing and turning it
into a religion turning it into some of
the greatest [ __ ] collection of words
ever put together to explain the dopey
concept of a plant man he turned it into
epic literature and so that that issue
the anatomy lesson is where you go from
realizing that he's the main character
the Swamp Thing is about to learn that
he will he's not who he thinks he is all
this time in the book he believes that
he was Alec Holland a scientist who's
covered by all this muck and if he could
just get this off of him he could free
himself but in that issue they find out
that like Alec Holland died this you're
a plant with the memories of being Alec
Holland and so there's a page that talks
about Sunderland Corp is like the
corporation that's like tracking down
Swamp Thing and this issue happened like
after the book had had a primary run
that where it was a more of a
traditional monster book he was fighting
the unmanned and he was fighting his
arch-nemesis of what's his [ __ ] name
arcane but when Alan Moore came in he
turned it into this incredible piece of
comic book writing that transcended the
medium and instantly went like right
into like it sounds ridiculous but right
up there with [ __ ] Shakespeare over
this vegetable thing like it was
mind-bending so the panel I have the
page I have is the page where there's a
guy who's like talking as a narrator and
he's discussing how the monster which
they're calling him and it's it's a it's
Swamp Thing the monster is intelligent
so he can read the scientists notes the
scientists dissected him to find out
that like this guy was never alive this
is not a long this is not a heart this
is what a vegetable thinks a heart and
lung would look like and he grows it
because he remembers being a man
he's now no longer a man he's going to
be an elemental so that information
would be [ __ ] really hard to digest
it would be like finding out you or
Christ like it's just like what the [ __ ]
but in the worst possible way because
this guy finds out he's never gonna be a
human being again
and so naturally he's [ __ ] like
pissed so on the page there's a line
which is fantastic where he says like
somebody's doing the narration talking
about how the monster found the notes
right about now the monster would be
reading about how he'll never be a man
again and stuff and then it's it's
refers to Sunderland the guy who's like
runs the facility that is captured him
and stuff and he's like and and one of
the last things is like the monster just
realized who's in charge
and your clothes on Sunderland space as
a window breaks he's about to be killed
the page was written and drawn got to be
close to 20 to 23 years ago at this
point maybe 30 I forget what year they
actually did it but I bought it long
time ago at a Comic Con found it for I
think at that point it was like a $200
page and it was like finding panning for
gold and finding a big [ __ ] nugget
like one of those things where I didn't
want to tell the person I was buying
like I I just I first wanted to say like
do you know what you have but I didn't
want to say that because I wanted to get
it for a price and [ __ ] and then the
dude who sold it to me was like you got
a really rare page I was like I know and
I [ __ ] ran with it so that is one of
my favorite long before I ever made
movies or wanted to be like [ __ ] who
I am and stuff like that I was just a
fan of that stuff and that Swamp Thing
run that made me a comic book fan I've
been one as a kid it's in my DNA and
[ __ ] but that brought me back into the
world where I was like this is what
comic books are nowadays so that page
still hangs in my office wall right by
the light switch the only thing up there
that I had nothing to do with but it's a
constant reminder of be as good as this
it's impossible but here's something to
reach for you are such a vegan
[Laughter]
oh I gave him my answer started this oh
I forgot that was a great question that
wins a booking tickets man give it up
farm well done and then since over here
our one couple man yeah they good
they're not gonna be here so they left
the tickets behind and stuff
we got one set of 40 X tickets we go for
bonus questions maybe pick somebody oh
it's our man who stood up with you right
there before what's your name my name is
Carson I gotta thank him for my
Redemption right now mispronouncing
Thanos that's not you heard before I
call them Han and hand so you know hands
you a microphone for the first time in
your life and says turn around there's a
[ __ ] camera
right there you say yes sorry sorry next
time somebody hands your microphone says
turn around don't take your eye off that
person right all right you got a
possibility of the books are gone but
you got a possibility of these couple
4dx
tickets compliments of Brett Deacon and
the good folks at 40x what is your
question I'm gonna bring us back to Star
Wars yeah I'm gonna try to honor
snip and go super sweaty with a theory
that I've had for like a month and dude
all right so the premise of my theory is
Knights of Ren
this is JJ Abrams baby so my theory is
they are currently disconnected from the
force they learned this from Luke
Skywalker he's teaching Rey all of these
things based off his you know knowledge
of Vader turning the hubris all of that
the visual dictionary shows us a Kyber
crystal red from a Jedi Crusader my
theory is a reven you may have found the
same holocron that Bane has found rule
of two bear with me bear with me I'm
with you so you're Luke Skywalker you've
discovered all of these things that made
you disconnect the reason for the
disconnect is that the long the stronger
he gets the stronger kylo Ren gets so
he's like
I'm gonna just disconnect and that whole
thing the whole balance
he teaches all of his students how to
disconnect the rule of two is him and
Ben solo only you see flashbacks for
Knights of Ren we know they're his
students that left with him they come
back none of them have lightsabers we
don't even know if they're force
sensitive
darkness rises light to meet it so I'm
asking you what you think about this
theory the Knights of Ren can still be
in play maybe they're sitting on mu
stefarr the new Vader comic that just
came out this month actually Vader
himself said that he believed things can
only happen in a nexus or a locus
whatever you want to call it on mu
stefarr octo those things he thinks that
you can only do things in those areas
you can only do stuff like disconnecting
so basically my theory is that Luke
didn't only know this ability but he
used it to his advantage to hide himself
or others learned what the Sith learned
that you'll destroy yourselves if
everybody is sharing the force so just
basically all those thoughts what do you
guys do I cosign that theory is that the
question yeah do you cosign that Luke
would have taken it upon himself to say
listen maybe the Sith had some of these
things right are the Knights of Ren
currently disconnected and maybe kylo
Ren can choose to teach them his own way
I do buy that it's also the blending of
two different movies right like it's
there's a bunch of force awakens in
there but also a bunch of last Jedi and
those are two separate DNA at this point
that saber seen when they're both
pulling on that and you know they're
equals in that moment yes but I feel
like there's a cap kind of on the force
and I know I'm gonna tangent off now go
ahead and kind of explain the shirtless
kylo Ren scene hear me out okay hear me
out I went back and I watched the last
Jedi through every scene like what
happened so the the moment when Luke
Skywalker tarika next to the force and
he calls out to Leia
he's like Leia and she awakens right
after that is the right before that
sorry is the scene where he's talking to
Ray a
the mosaic and the hubris and all of
this so that scene happens then Luke
reconnects the very next scene is ray
force skyping or whatever you want to
call it with kylo Ren that's winning
tickets right there wait for skyping
with the shirtless kylo Ren so Snoke
Snow Keys you know floating around there
he immediately sensed Luke Luke's
reconnect freaks the [ __ ] out and he's
like I got a distract Rey connects her
with kylo immediately doesn't care what
kylo is doing he's shirtless to distract
her right after that he's like how can I
distract this female Jedi because he
know what shirtless boy so then you keep
going down in the scenes you keep going
down after that happens he reconnects
them again in the Hutt scene he's trying
to distract her the whole time Luke
shows up freaks out like freaks out bad
that they're touching and connecting so
I all right here's my philosophy I think
we can't I think it's tough to piece
together because of not because of the
story that they're telling but because
never the other sides no not even that
but because the way I see the Star Wars
situation from the outside I don't know
anything but this is what it looks like
to an outsider and I've read a few
articles it kind of backs it up JJ did
his thing Ryan did whatever he wanted
and his thing just like JJ did whatever
he wanted Ryan did whatever he wanted
and some of what Ryan did undoes some of
what JJ set up so Knights of Ren was
like that was a big [ __ ] deal in
force awakens and then it's kind of
discarded in last Jedi I think now that
JJ is coming back to make the third Star
Wars movie I think a lot of those ideas
including [ __ ] the Knights of Ren
will probably come back into play to me
it looked like from the outside you know
a storyteller going like I like that but
I don't want to do that I'm gonna do my
story that this is how I'm gonna tell
the story but now that the first guy is
returning
I would imagine he's gonna bring some of
his elements back into play like you
know there's
there's no way that you could possibly
complete the trilogy without a
thought-out story first right maybe I'm
the only one that thinks that but just
handing the baton off thing without
knowing what your endgame thing is
Marvel can pull it off because it's
growing and they have also they've got a
guy in the god seat right telling a
story for electoral fog ease level there
is somebody in charge with an overview
there who is telling one long-form story
doesn't feel like that's what's going on
on Star Wars you have to retcon I feel
like some things it would not surprise
me if going in to like in force awakens
Kathy Kennedy was like where does this
story end we have to know where it's
ending and JJ you're talking towards
that Ryan you're tacking towards that
you were all you're both going to end up
putting the tracks on the way to that
final Depot that terminal which again
it's not the final Depot it's that we we
keep going like well it's over after
9:00 and they've never said that yeah
totally you're gonna keep going believe
me there'll be episode 10 11 12 we'll
leave this world that beyond episode 99
the gretzky episode and [ __ ] I don't
think they're stopping no but I think
there was a sense of at least this will
be a trilogy and there will be trilogies
after this and Ryan will go off and do
his own separate one and the game yeah
but like this particular this this part
of the saga will come to some semblance
of the Skywalker's saw Skywalker saga
and they would have to know what that
ending is I don't I don't believe that
they start telling the story without a
sense of what its gonna be when it winds
up but it always changes like the the
route you were taking to get to that
ending always changes when you're
telling that kind of story and sometimes
the destination changed I don't [ __ ]
want to go there anymore like I thought
that was gonna be interesting to me and
when I got there not as much fun as I
thought it was going to be so there's a
world in which it's always evolving it's
constantly evolving but I believe that
you don't start spending what will be
six hundred million dollars worth of
money without a sense of what that last
couple of beets were going to be and
harmony would have to be part of that
what's your over-under
odds on Knights of Ren having a major
like major factor over/under I say they
I say there's reference and they pop up
but I don't think it's like the plot of
the next one although that would be
fantastic if like JJ in the first one
I'm doing Knights of Ren and then all of
a sudden Ryan made a move in [ __ ] and
that discarded it and be awesome if JJ
came back he goes as I was saying I mean
yeah and it's all [ __ ] Ren action man
and I'm a huge Star Wars fan my only
criticism of the Rian Johnson film is
that it took place over a week week or
two is that right month maybe like Star
Wars though but you watched them chase
them through space I agree but I mean
just thinking backwards how Star Wars
takes place over a couple days like you
know it's like first one like for the
movie star wars new hope
yeah the [ __ ] droids land on Tatooine
they get picked up
sold to the Skywalker and his uncle and
[ __ ] and then also
[Laughter]
stormtroopers kill his [ __ ] family and
then then he meets Ben Kenobi and then
[ __ ] hey man let's go to the town and
then they get up in space oh [ __ ] the
Death Star's got us and then we're
getting away and we're gonna go blow up
[ __ ] Gavin and that's I'm telling you
that takes place over the span of a
weeks not that yeah yeah yeah I mean
there could be there could be time jumps
between them I mean they do in the
movies movies I mean like the time
between when Vader captures Leia and the
the escape right could be a couple of
days right it could be a week Matt in no
way because they keep cutting to the
other story and that's still going on
like he's getting there crossing over
and stuff you know I don't know how long
it is between when they are
at what's-his-face the [ __ ] rebel
headquarters and they watch the assault
yeah I don't know how like that could be
a week for all we know I see in my head
it's fast because the Empire knows where
they are they've put a tracking device
on the [ __ ] Falcon right no we know
where they're gonna be knows how far
away it is I don't know it could be
longer it feels like in story time it's
like four days there was a nice
representation of space travel in the
predator today I thought where they
ripped open space and then jumped
through it in space closed well that was
kind of cool spoilers yeah it's in the
trailer I believe and I don't know if
you guys I'm not gonna predator comes
from outer space that was that took us
in places man you get some [ __ ]
tickets give it up for man
[Applause]
[Music]
very Knights of Ren [ __ ] man I really
hope for your benefit that [ __ ]
curtain comes up and it's just nothing
but non-stop Knights of Ren action look
I love nobody's wearing a shirt
everybody hairless and topless there all
shirtless with scars on their faces with
some girl do you want a space Skype what
you call it for skyping you want a for
Skype [ __ ] no that sounds hard I got my
lightsaber all right man we're out of
[ __ ] stuff to give away that means
we're done with the Q&A all guys did
great but when we're done with the QA
that means we're done with the [ __ ]
show we've got no more show left to give
you man the very first episode of fat
man Beyond is coming to a close man we
don't get to do this without the [ __ ]
bar so give it up for JC and the scum
and villainy Cantina we don't get to do
this without the guys standing to my
left so give it up for my team mark
Bernardo
and that is Fatman beyond for this week
man I'm Kevin Smith hi I'm mark Barnard
tune in next time same bat-time same
bat-channel SModcast calm or
youtube.com/ so that's Kevin Smith
[Applause]